so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
what is going
on the lord's
day has returned
yeah we go alive earlier we kind of go
around this time you know what i mean
yo shout out to tyson
aaa studios highest support studios and
contractors to make their games
quadruple a studios higher aaa studios
to help make their games initiative
flexible
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
i'm quiet
[Music]
thank you i am quiet
i should be at my normal level now thank
you thank you
cat
daddy
lurk what's going on
my guy been there for a minute thank you
xcode for the level
recognition you know what i'm saying
ksanti the homie what's going on it's
good podcasting with you just recently
on boom show attic in the building
getting back to his mic right now
i'm saying he had his little fresh
dapper look you should you see them out
here see your boy out here he's out here
looking fresh
dylan b what's up what's up
what's going on
don't let negative energy consume you
grow the dislike that means they came
here to dislike that's engagement
they took the time out they they don't
like news
[Music]
they still they still contributed to a
view
of contributing to some form of uh
interaction i love that we all need my
head that's funny to me yes they have a
positive
i had to get a little mic check to the
people
can't say he loved that halo flight he
might be a new halo fan what's going on
tcl in the building
[Music]
the king will be rolling through i spoke
to him earlier of course
we're going to do it really big today
and oh man i got the super chat flying
there george louis
shout out to five dollar super chat
first time watching live found the iron
laws from an unlocked excite yo salute
man definitely um salute ryan mccaffrey
the whole podcast online pretty much had
everyone
minus
destiny which we are working on getting
on but thank you for finding us and
today's a celebration we're gonna get
king phoenix in the building and um
jay-z stupid he said i'm finally able to
afford a tcl i'm living the dream you
are hilarious anyway we will be back
listen to my man dallas spit some bars
it's a celebration today y'all
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on
[Music]
that i'm very spoiled for them to be
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boy you
ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed for
you i always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social lower my city but i'm
still by coastal
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
[Music]
i'm very spoiled for them to be your dog
thing very loyal but i ain't gonna hold
you i ain't here to boy you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell an uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look
gotta messed up and turn me to an animal
and headless be swearing they real but
come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got
[Music]
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when
um
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check
[Music]
your dogs ain't very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boy you
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that
again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beating they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it um
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled put on the b.o dog thing very
loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't
here to boil you you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you're gonna be
single player like siren you're gonna
get tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though i
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it and nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable because you can listen to this
in your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
all right
here you hear ye and we are live and
welcome
to the 10k
sub count iron law podcast llc put your
damn hands together
delicious smells delicious whoa it
smells delicious oh my god
yo what's up did that
oh
it was all natural like you know we we
we did it our own way when they told us
to do specifically
we did it our own way
well they said we couldn't have certain
guests or you say it was all natural
check out that all daddy
y'all been y'all
[Music]
i i i didn't get a chance to talk to
saul before the podcast
uh
i'm giving away like almost all the
games we had oh okay okay let's go
celebration
the iron bank were replenished
so stop letting us have free rape yeah
we got a lot of show and we got uh
against all over the top so we got to be
respectful but uh welcome to episode 226
and it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date i'm extremely excited about our
special guest and we've got i always
butch is it kendall canada kate i always
canada it's kind of cana impressions
thank you
perfect doc the initiative plus crystal
dynamics and the latest nintendo direct
to discuss so we're going to get right
into it
i want to introduce a lord who says
advice to fellow content creators and
consistent evolution within the realm of
variety streaming truly mimics his
fitting namesake as a king on the rise
introducing
the created host of the phoenix 443
twitch channel xbox ambassador and black
game pro's partner
the lord of horror streams and the
beyhive
who will still give fanboy foot locker
employees all the smoke
live from an undisclosed location by way
of g.a and making his debut into the
realm of the lord
my man message scene dm
lord king phoenix how are we doing sir
yo
what's good
look i'm glad to be here for a couple of
reasons number one king is now my new
best friend
so we're just gonna put that out there
and i've been uh
uh a fan of this show for quite some
time so hey congratulations on the 10k
you did it naturally thank you
[Laughter]
thank you thank you but i got i got
people in the statute community that
dwarf mind make mine put mine to shame
my boy mojo crazy as hell that's crazy
somebody putting that machine that's
crazy you know what's going on yes sir
mojo crazy yeah can't fix it you know
you're a lawyer look at what you do good
at it
you need to stop saying from an
undisclosed location because well you
can make it seem like they they do doing
the podcast from like areas
bunkers
sometimes you know a certain people i
get to read that they know what they put
this out so what you're doing
you know you don't want 1650
[Music]
kennedy boulevard like we enjoyed that
what you do man what you been playing
man what's been going on with you
i have just recently got back into
destiny 2. oh
and i'm on a hunt to get
they're going to kill me when i say this
it's it's a weapon that you get where
you shoot fire out of it and then it
explodes like okay okay there's a bunch
there's a bunch of those is it is it um
when it shoots the lava on the floor
then it kind of like leaves the track
and it explodes that way oh ain't that
um a thousand voices though
i'm on the hunt for it and one of my
friends got it literally when we did the
raid the other day and i'm like
oh we we love this popping of the the
moe yeah let's go baby listen i'm going
to tell y'all
baby
we got that dog
i don't be drinking enough to be knowing
these names well drake would be without
if y'all see the cup
it says
king david otw there you go i'll give a
shout out shout out to lord
the wall the wall baby
shout out to well i'm screaming there
you know what i'm saying first six
figures i had no doubt but like you
would say so you would do it you were
doing destiny that that's been it any
other things you got a chance to play uh
psychonauts two
uh kina i messed up the last part of
that title yeah um
and then the halo was going past
i said
soon to be on game pass
that part yeah
you want to start they're flowing in a
bit i don't want to get too behind yeah
yeah yeah celebrities yeah it's a couple
of super chats all right let's start off
with tyson
i'm sorry if i butchered that eight
dollar super chat triple a studios
higher support studios and contractors
to help help make their games quadruple
a studios hire aaa studios to help make
their games initiative flexi flex
then we got george lewis five dollar
super chat first time watching live
found iron lords from unlocked excited
thank you sir and welcome to the realm
then we have remember for 23 months
shout out to stitch
i think it's 29 months right it's 20
23 yeah i don't have one i'm half blind
that's the most
[Laughter]
all i want to know is how much time is
king going to have at the podium today
i don't know
what else you get
remember for five months thank you my
brother we've been watching for almost a
year and joined five months ago and
haven't regretted it thank you sir
love much appreciated brother
then we have harget chani two dollar
super chat congrats on 10k now let's get
to a hundred cases
let's let's let's aim for 10k first
fellas
to take over which else we got and we
got the human encyclopedia slow-mo
backslap member for 16 months thank you
my brother
what up fellas congrats on 10k y'all
even did it while occasionally
mentioning that trash bag of a game
destiny
my man slow
are you putting destiny uh division two
in there with killzone yeah yeah with
the great likes of anthem and killzone
kickface is like yo y'all messy i can
assure you definitely
messy but geez no no this is this is
as in he's playing the wrong guy yes
correct yeah yeah yeah that's right he
just don't really laugh he's no longer
playing you know let's point that out
did they shut off the service
we have okay i don't understand what
you're trying to say here um maybe
because i'm old we have a something
might be trashed herb
whenever he sees a nintendo topic
stitching oh yeah you know about now he
do about that so apparently sister's not
like greenery okay
maybe that's his bush's emote exactly
there you have everyone's idol goro five
pound super attack congratulations on
this huge milestone it's fantastic to
see a die hard sega fanboys show
take a fan boy sir get the recognition
it deserves 10k baby
when are we lining up for the super
mario brothers movie
tune in later this week lady lyric and i
will have a lord's minute
breaking down and analyzing this some
this uh quote air quote amazing cast
i can't wait i can't wait
and big shout out to hustle and bump
thank you brother joining the realm and
of course the co-host of the attic show
yes sir no doubt and we got cedric h ten
dollars for chat 10k congrats to the
most humble and most uh most of all
entertaining dudes in the community
salute lords thank you thank you thank
you
then we got reggie mobile nine five
dollar super chat
happy 10k day lord salute 10k there i
like that i like that i like that that
sounds
then we got chancleta mango
a chopped cheese on friday it was good
that's alone did you have it aki style
what was it it was a i had it i was
dipping it in aioli excuse me
that's very very
glad to see the homie king phoenix in
the realm congrats on tim
thank you here's to adding another zero
to that number yeah that's it
then we got the man who got them horns
thank you for showing out sir much love
on the 10k keep taking knees and
throwing frogs in the bushes as we look
at these guys we'll always be taking
your exactly every guy digital swords
five dollars of attack congratulations
on the 10k long time listener first
super chat keeper oh wow oh thank you
thank you much appreciated man
pixel bit g five dollar super chat
congrats and many more tens of thousands
worth of slander from the lord well
earned
it
let's get it covered we have the homer
yeah we have we have the homie joe mac
big shout out to joe joe oh yeah salute
out there on twitter putting the word
out
uh getting the troops behind us and we
got it done brother thank you thank you
general mack for real all hail the iop
salute on that milestone thank you my
brother thank you so much
and we got delilah hd my women who are
my sisters my grown women sisters
25 super chat thank you so much congrats
on the 10k much love from grown woman
gaming lou for that big shout out thank
you yes much love then we have rrd 2
super chat congrats on 10k xbox
community is the best no doubt period
period
yeah
you got it
put a dot dot dot period
no slander against the emerald kingdom
today
tony bryant member for 14 months thank
you sir 10k congrats can't wait for 100k
y'all got me hungry early with chopped
cheese
i'll tell you right now you already know
we got the four hospital of gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table with some a little bit of
time sensitive because we got to respect
phoenix's time intros
my man my co-host with the cole most my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the heart of the young wolf my
man lord addict how are we doing sir
doing pretty good man i've been playing
that halo infinite beta all right it's
uh whoa technical test uh i'm enjoying
it man i'm enjoying it appreciate her
coming through
this is how the codes are gonna be
distributed i'm gonna give a couple
otherwise just dropping in the chat but
i know some of you in that chat it's
unfair you got that copy and pasting
down way too easy
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna look down
and i'm gonna i'm gonna find some trivia
questions to throw in that chat too yeah
because i've noticed i've noticed when i
just saw them throw them in the chat
like the same way
and i wanted to be a little bit fair but
for the first one uh let me get the
individual what we're going to do is
give away i think it was a three month
ex uh game pass ultimate wasn't it okay
yes sir sir yes sir and yeah yeah i
checked the um the group chat because i
said there's another something else came
in today too
unreckoned i believe unreckoning is
unreckoned or unreckoned
right on reckoner on reckoner unreckoned
appreciate the uh the donation to uh the
chat
so what we're going to do is i'm going
to throw that in there right now
get that um you know my fingers ready
[Laughter]
i'm going to do what i've seen mikey bar
do i'm going to put a question mark for
one of them nice so uh
yeah that copy you gonna have to work
get your 26 letters on that's right
that's right mm-hmm there you go i like
that all that kind of faces
no doubt so that's it sir yeah it's you
know um it's it's been a a farley
fairly not far early i don't know it's
too early man it's too early when can we
go back to the wall again
petition right now
you're looking extra chris yeah
i saw you at the rounds nice it looks
nice yeah i saw the suit what's funny
i woke up yesterday okay
bro he was clean i woke up last night i
woke up last night and i was like
yesterday morning oh yeah that's the
type of daddy i woke up yesterday
morning and i was like do i really need
to go to this wedding i was like damn it
i'm in it i can't just not go
i learned a long time ago never commit
to those
what's funny is
is a message my friend evan
and i'm like how important is it that i
show up to the sweat he's like well
you're the best
[Laughter]
am i the only one that loves to show up
to a wedding just so i can show off my
tom ford
no see you see it it's nice to just show
up and go to a wedding if you're part of
the what i've learned a long time ago
business not a responsibility one at all
and what's funny is like the the
bridesmaid that i walked down the aisle
with was so slow because she was so
short so i'm so tall she's so short and
i feel like i'm walking down this aisle
going like a step wait five seconds
but it was it was a good wedding man
and of course we have our tech most
technical gaming lord the solo gamer
list for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastradamus the
lord of clarity and lord patron of the
iron bank mommy lord sovereign how are
we doing sir i'm doing good man i'm
doing good i didn't expect to get a lot
of gaming in this week and i
yesterday kind of like opened up in a
way that was surprisingly cool because
you know saturdays is the day for myself
and wifey you know just to be together
whatever she had a last minute work
thing so i was like
[Laughter]
are you excited she get to go you get to
play that's hilarious so even then i had
like errands and stuff to do but i you
know i put everything on a balance and i
was like do i really do these errors
right now you know you see the last
couple of weeks i've been shaved and
nice and i was like do i need to take
two and a half hours out of my day
[Music]
so first uh in terms of watching i've
been watching uh the the star wars
visions the anime uh sort of anthology
first episode
oh yeah they go they go all over the
place kind of like the animatrix right i
started watching the second one i didn't
finish the second one but that first
episode
afro samurais failed too yeah
okay yeah very cool very cool um you
like anime you like star wars please
watch that okay is it the what if so no
it's not what it is this is a star wars
thing yeah that's a marble it's on
disney plus
yeah man they're they they they're
overwhelming me yeah they kill them on
the show
disney doing such
i haven't even really i haven't even
really got to consume the what-ifs yet
and now you're telling me there's
something else
every wednesday i tune in that's my view
oh they come on wednesday every
wednesday every weekend
okay the visions the visions came out in
one shot
and they're short they're like 15
minutes long each so they win another
night
okay
fantastic so that obviously i've been
playing some cana i got about five hours
in canada absolutely
some stuff to talk about um oh and of
course well thank you for uh
beta-boring
he's like yeah he's like do you want
keen i was like that's all you've done
know that and real quick oh bro
all i have to say is act razor oh
we gonna get into it we gonna get it so
that and obviously the captain
collection because i fell off of the
game boy advance i was you know playing
big boy games when the game boy advance
was hot and i was not about having the
little like the little spiral light i
was not about that yeah i left that for
kaibatsu so i played a little bit of
those games
knowing full well that i love those
metroidvanias so to be able to you know
deep dive into them now it's fantastic
no doubt no doubt and of course we have
the incredible hulk of this aka the xs
gamer oh
the prophet of xbox swami
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing better than anthony joshua oh yeah
oh my god my boy alexander usyk put some
paws on that boy
i told now if you ever follow me you
have a list and you want to make some
bread you want to make some money listen
to what i'm going to give you i'm going
to give you the analyzation of the fight
i told you your man had a 55 chance of
winning that fight only because i knew
it was gonna go the distance and i
wanted to know if they was going to
cheat oh boy one boy went in there and
put them paws all over him like he stole
money he was hitting him all over the
place and then it got to the 12th round
and then he just said you know what
it's time for me to beat the brakes off
i've been around here long enough i'm
trying to take you home
mind you mind you the man is a
cruiserweight oh man isn't it
he's not a true heavyweight but no man
chin always been a suspect right this is
god no it wasn't even the chin though
yeah
let me tell you about it the whole
situation is wings he ate the night
before
pepper of course
right tell the truth oh so he's um he
was the unified cruiserweight champion
he did something that only evander
holyfield done
before that all right and then he went
up and he fought the heavyweight
champion which was um joshua
and took all his belts so now fury has
to fight deontay wilder on the sixth i
believe he's gonna go to sleep he's
gonna get slapped because he can't cheat
so we found out yeah
the crackheads gonna go to sleep and i
know i know that hurt a lot of you hey
how are you
no no he do drugs now anytime you got
bloody good come on man he was doing
drugs and stuff like that it was
official
this is a legend
solve i need verification so no he he
has been known to partake on the side
hold on i feel like i need
[Laughter]
if you remember when you know he got
dropped and then he stood up like he was
yeah yeah i remember that was the crazy
baby there's a reason behind that that
was that was the coat kick oh man
all right so the stuff that i've been
playing this week
check this out so game pass has been
doing these little stealth drops here
and there right so um lost words um my
son is playing that okay and i think
that that game is really ridiculous
where it uses the words to build the
world uh like it'll be bridge or on
unmake or whatever words forming the
game which is incredible from what i saw
i downloaded it didn't get a chance to
play it yet but i played sable
sable is something that i saw on the
xbox show that looked phenomenal to me
and i was like i could not wait for it
to drop and there was like no hoopla
about it and it dropped inside game pass
and i'm like this is kind of crazy okay
so um
subnautics
it was um it felt like no man's sky
underwater okay okay
right so
and i guess that's the accurate feel to
it i uninstalled it very quickly
it was that's that's more like a
survival game right it's more like you
gotta get like yeah yeah you gotta you
gotta go yeah yeah okay you're not about
that
i already got destiny sapping up my life
so i guess i ain't got no time for that
but origami too
let's go put your attention
just download
let's get to the ninjas okay so remember
origami one like when we knew origami
two was coming out we everybody went
back to play origami and you knew how
bad the controls yeah yeah
the controls on this is what i said
please fix it yes i feel really nice
sliding up behind somebody pause
just i got the choice to knock them out
handle them later pause
oh oh oh
then i grab them and i like to hide the
bodies i'm one of those dudes like i
don't want nobody to know that she was
missing
it allows me to get my sneak on fast i
love the game um shout out to luca me
and luca uh she did two raids this week
um she made me dust off my hunter okay
okay my hunter felt like my playstation
haven't been used in months
[Laughter]
but it was so much fun
we completed the raids and uh gurley got
the the mythic ass awesome girl shout
out to tasks got the vex too finally
after like 57 tries five years six
months
that's that's all i've been doing um
other than that uh
just popping bottles no doubts popping
by 10k
you know we do and of course we got the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi lord
cognito spreading that realism around
the iop not telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear yo shout
out to wanna duke shout out to mr maddie
plays we had two episodes go up we had
one with the amazing hog lord talking
about that legal situation with bungie
and marty o'donnell about music very
good listen and me and homie was also
talking shout out to the last
word ibontist thai guy travis we have
paul tassie on serious debate
serious trials beef i mean
it was contentious let's just say that
there's a lot of lines i agree with a
lot of people because i'm out here
winning in trouble yeah i i called
travis i was like i don't think you feel
a kid going to the lighthouse i said
because he one of those
child's elitists yeah sorry brother
they don't let me in once we all joke
what it is is travis wanted to take
other people to the white house he don't
want them going themselves
he just wants a competitive uh pvp with
ranking so he did that and uh yeah other
than that um playing a little bit like i
said that's he sees the loss got that
agent scepter been doing that and yes
king
beta boy hayla and smith we out here
infinite i was doing it for three four
three wait wait wait wait what was you
doing it over was you doing
little man was out here on the halo
infinite bear let's go
little bit let's
in the bedroom you know still got that
same performance for the most part with
my halo infinite little man
series is doing this little man for that
bedroom he put in that workplace fast
you know for the for the living room you
need that big guy in the living room but
for the bedroom you need that you know
dude that's in there man
he punched above his weight low man be
punching bumping shot
does little man work
better than the playstation oh see you
oh
but you know i'm not trying to sound
like a foot locker employer those days
are long gone those days are long gone
we were chilling out we were trying to
get into something
that's what it's been pretty much for me
on the game attempt and uh i think ride
four but it's not in game pass i'm
seeing some clips of it they got the
next time yeah it looked really cool
it looked really crazy it took me back
yeah we'll get into that but anyway look
at it north phoenix got up no no you
have no ufc
um i quote
the highlight but i didn't see i heard
no the nomas
something a little bit more popular than
oh damn oh
the next code will be a bioshock trivia
so that the chat be wired no i gotta
find one though i gotta find that no
doubt no doubt now i did see the no
monster go down and anything else did i
miss off real quick yeah i mean again
valentina sevchenko just is just
murdering everyone that stands in front
of her oh she's doing her thing yeah
right robbie lawler avenging his loss to
nick diaz
and and the volk versus brian o'take
classic
excellent fight i'll tell you this
though like i don't think brian o'taker
gave everything that he had but and and
he did what moments he almost had to
vote but i just think ever since bless
put them hands on them it was he's not
the same he's not the fan yeah it's
holloway he's not the same that fight
probably took some years off his life
yes yes that has been it but uh look we
got this special guest we got we got
what the laws have been playing i want
to focus on lord king phoenix his video
game system history his journey into
content creation and of course we'll let
him be starting the amazing phoenix
podcast as well as the phoenix 443
twitch channel so lord phoenix let's
start from the very beginning was some
of the first video game systems you had
and what got you into gaming
my dad god rest his soul uh was a marine
and
he came home with this
gray box called the nes and i'm like
what the world is this thing he pulls
his track pad out and his gun
and he's the type that step you know
stood back and was shooting from a
distance on duck hunt and me i'm just
like yeah no give me the screen to put
up against
oh you were you was that kid
i i was that kid
i was also that kid if i'm playing you
and madden and you're beating me i'm
unplugging your controller in the middle
wow
the most
i think uh
what made me fall in love with gaming
was
uh and i said this on unlock this indie
game called halo combat evolve
my mom came home i was in the 10th grade
i was sitting in and i remember like it
was yesterday i was sitting in uh what
is that algebra class because god i was
bored i hate algebra
and
my mom actually use it day to day like
why did he give us stuff that we ain't
using day to day that's
my mom had like text me while i was in
class we had those old nokia phones you
could play snake on it yeah
and she text me she's like what was that
thing you wanted again i was like a
playstation 2.
so i was like all right so she went to
gamestop toys r us and then she went to
funko land
and
i came home and i saw this big black and
green box of like
what is this thing i didn't ask for this
plugged it up
me and the chief been best friends ever
since oh that's what's happening to your
mom for having the foresight to save you
that part
this boy
[Laughter]
that's so crazy
so initially you was he was a little
tight he was a little upset with when
she
yeah because my cousin had managed to
find a playstation 2. we're not going to
say the means of which yeah
it's neither here nor there
but um
i'm like
i don't i don't like you
you know
like who why are you rubbing this in my
face and now here we are 20 years later
my same cousin switched over to the
emerald mm-hmm
when xbox sent me that good old pride
controller for june yes he's like
what are you kidding me and i'm like
karma
[Laughter]
what's the police station send you
messy
lovely water bottles
such
[Music]
are you trying to say that all
playstation guys are thirsty
you are messy
and then i see you on twitter and this
is the funny thing like i'll see ken
going back and forth on twitter i'm like
oh i want to jump in but i'm like nope
nope i'm gonna be good you're doing it
right you're doing the right thing
you're doing it right
real quick cause i know i know you
talked about the gaming and um obviously
you know
halo like i said
this this amazing feeling game like just
really quickly because i know this is
halo season like what was it about halo
that made you fall that in love that
you're like yo i am staying in this
ecosystem
i want to say it was halo 2. i worked at
best buy at the time and when the store
would close we would all bring our
xboxes to that wall of tvs and we would
hook them up and do this huge land party
oh we was acting
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was i think that's that's what made
me fall in love with halo and i went to
the howard university so we had
[Music]
yes absolutely we had um lan parties in
on the dorm room so i think for me that
it was just a sense of community and
i'm not going to talk bad about the
franchise in the last game and all that
noise i obviously infinite is showing
that they know what they're doing
but to me it
i think
that game was the game that i was like i
have to be a part of this industry
somehow
and
i guess the rest is history at that
point that is fire so you had that you
had the tremendous experience you stayed
the ecosystem so from that point on it
was just a natural progression to the
you know as far as 360 and everything
else and did you ever when did you ever
get back into the playstation ecosystem
if ever
it's not that i i ever left because i
was doing my podcast heavily at that
time which i'm kind of revamping at this
point but
i'm the type of person i feel as though
you can't comment on something that you
don't own preach and yeah i think i'm my
family i'm a fan of that you know i
think for me when i when you go online
and you see grown
adults
you know talking trash about companies
that they don't work for let alone own a
good amount of stock to sit at the board
oh don't you sound like kids
i feel like especially on my timeline
i just feel like if you're a content
creator
you should be able to have access to all
gaming platforms and different ways of
playing games in order to specifically
talk about those specific individual
ecosystems and what they provide to
consumers
and if i don't own platforms i'm not
doing my job as a content creator and i
can't properly speak across
the ecosystem tell the truth shame you
know what's you know what's funny people
people are taking that kind of mentality
and they're going extra with the okay
you say i can't comment on the console
if i don't own it so they'll literally
waste five hundred dollars to buy the
car voted for the wednesday just so they
could say they could criticize them
they didn't buy it to play it they
didn't buy it
i know what you mean
literally bought it just to keep it in
the box to show the picture on twitter
and and boot up the ui to complain about
the ui and then not even play the games
and just complain about all the games
the interesting piece of that though and
i remember people when the the series x
and ps5 first came out right oh ps5
feels next-gen and the xbox series x
feels like last year well let's do a
little bit of research here because phil
specifically said over the summer before
it launched uncle phil spencer
uncle phil but he's feeling dominance
maximus of really expensive hair
i didn't really get all the
supercalifragilistic expertise
um
i couldn't write that down that was a
lot to go down
[Music]
you know but i think he even said over
the summer before it launched we want to
keep the same ecosystem so it feels a
part of the same like it's on brand
right and i think people uh
filter in and out what they want
and to me it's just like if
okay case in point i'll go back to walt
disney uh when kevin when uh
was getting ready to debut feige the
show runner the director all came out
and said
the show is not what you expect right
the first half of the series
is not going to be on brand for marvel
the latter half is gonna be able to pick
up and then people were complaining and
i'm like
they put statements out there were
interviews like what are we paying
attention to so that's the same way i
look at it in terms of gaming like
i don't know i'm getting it i say this
right i saw i i saw when the playstation
interface and and i saw a lot of people
uh saying that the playstation user
interface was in 4k
and a lot of these dudes have tcl
televisions and they can't display 4k so
i'm like why are you championing
something that you can't truly see i'm
just i'm just saying you know
let's see you you more in line with the
other stuff that ain't 4k like you
supposed to be saying they did this for
you because they did
they knew he wasn't ready i do want to
point out that coming from the person
that had the tca
a former representative of the tcl
community
there is a difference but it's not it's
not the difference that you guys are
actually happy with like it's just but
you can't go back though
i mean
it would be harder for me to go back but
i'm just saying like that's kicking the
screen the difference the difference
between i'd rather have a tcl than have
an xbox series s
like because
because the difference
is man
how it is
it's not a push
thing it's it's about like
what i
went through with the xbox one and the
xbox one x like i'm not going to have
that difference in power anymore because
to me like when i had the xbox one s and
kids food had the x i saw more of an
advantage him being on the x than him
being on a better team performance you
know
yeah yeah
nothing but let's get let's get back on
track with phoenix and again stay in the
ecosystem obviously you said you know
you want to
probably get back into it and then
you'll be able to talk more about the
other ecosystems but right now xbox is
what's keeping you there that's what's
up and then um just really quickly all
the way up until the current generation
you just stayed through and through oh
that's right um any i know you started
with nes but any
other nintendo systems as well during
the course
i've had every
console from nes to present i think
my favorite console
which
i would either say it save that save
that save that though because that's
coming that's gonna be enough okay say
that one but um so you you've had okay
cool so you're pretty but you you've
been you've been in the ecosystems
you've had very much so yeah you had it
we gotta talk about that so let me move
on a little bit because i know like i
said time a little bit but i want to
talk about obviously you know podcasting
and um you know the first time i came
across your content i believe we were
both still at tick at the time without
the cow but
yeah when i first yeah that's what i
first came about that's when i checked
out the high energy the opinions of this
uh
phoenix podcast
very
very spicy and very opinionated so uh
tell us about the origin story of that
and i know you've been doing it for a
long time like since 2008 was that your
initial venture into content creation i
also want to ask you that too it was
2008 was my initial venture um shout
outs to danny in paris because
they put me on and they've been in my
ear since then
i was a part of another show at a time
which i won't get into but um
i think it
i had started wanting to
do my own show i'm a virgo so i'm
naturally like
i want to touch everything and figure
everything out and
i also kind of had to sit back and think
there's nobody at that time that
is a part of the lgbt community in black
that's actually putting themselves out
there
and i wanted to be the representation
that i
never saw growing up
um
so that's when i started my own show and
good lord in heaven um we're gonna talk
about them days we're gonna talk about
it because
i'm a very opinionated individual right
and
to me i don't know i
growing up with the way that i grew up
you had to have a strong opinion and you
had to know how to uh back your opinion
if you understand what i'm saying that's
right you have to know how to knuckle
them down
hold your own
hands like alexander
they come at you with the words with the
verbal
so for me it was like
i was a lot of the stuff that i said
looking in hindsight was more
you young and stupid you don't even know
how to
you know to me and now that you've
i've grown up
and started doing content creation and
seeing things it's kind of like
okay you were one of those trolls online
before and
that's when i kind of took a step back
again and i was like i'm going to focus
on twitch and
handle that and then now i'm kind of
like i want to dive back into podcasting
again because i have so much fun talking
about different stuff and then obviously
now without going into detail there's
certain stuff i
can't now talk about right because you
know
yeah so not so good that's where we are
how did that change like when you were
able to be free to talk about whatever
and then now like it's like oh man i
can't talk about that right there so how
do you navigate around that and still be
you
i think
the best way that i can handle that is
play dumb
if that makes sense
and i think that's the the quickest way
for a not to get in trouble and then b
you're just able to
still enjoy the conversation because
again it sucks when you
know stuff and you're like you know it's
you know it's funny phoenix i knew about
that dead space thing for like a minute
like six seven months before it was
formally announced
you know how many discords or podcasts
have people's like man
like like uh you know we're never gonna
get another dead space and i'm like
you know you know what's the worst thing
my community loves the bad people they
love it
and then i remember i was a i was in a
discord where they were arguing if
there's ever going to be another uh
death space and then people started
saying the words i bet you oh
jump in the video about to jump into
that
welfare you have to continue
but no i think um
it's it's it's a unique situation to say
the least and it's a blessed situation
to say the least so sure for sure you
always of course you know what i wanted
you transitioned perfectly because i
definitely wanted to talk about your
passion as a variety streamer you know
it's like so how did that kind of start
and then
whose idea was it for you to be
streaming these
horror games damn they're scared to die
like
my community actually i was playing
i was playing some horror game
and i just saw like the numbers just
start going up and i'm like
all right so then
it's funny because i keep this behind me
because i would throw this over my face
in a heartbeat and something crazy comes
up
and um it was it was definitely my
community in
the story of how i got into streaming
shout outs to my best friend we actually
met on xbox throwing gears uh the
original gears in 360.
i kept saying i want to do streaming i
want to do streaming i know i can do
this
for my birthday last year
he
bought the parts and built me a pc
and said
go for it oh and that's what's up that's
what's up man you know
he said stop talking about it
you know what's funny like when it comes
to like the horror stuff i don't know if
technically alien isolation is
technically calling a horror game
that's the only game that gets my blood
going man i stopped i couldn't keep you
there
like it's one of those games where i'm
holding my breath because i feel like
the alien will hear me
you see this engagement the homie gets
you to pc you know what i mean so
continue all with this whole chance of
horror streaming let's go
i oh god what was it phasmaphobia had
came out okay and
uh let's just say i got inebriated
before i started
playing this game it's the right thing
to do yes yeah
and i was playing with three friends at
the time and we i was streaming and
i almost had a heart attack on stream
because i'm like freaking out i'm like
oh my god i can't do this what the hell
is this oh my god
and it was a game called visage i think
that was the tipping point where i knew
okay we're onto something here and
i had this blanket over my face like i
said okay i'm moving up
so you wasn't even
you were streaming halves with high
sight sure was yeah sure was
like
because i'm half dominican we don't play
with that demonic stuff no no no no no
no no
we don't play with that dr building
shout out to my wife that knew you was
dominican uh so she laid up she just saw
you and she i can show you the text yeah
oh watch she's like
i'm not i'm not even gone
oh she got the flag y'all oh yes guys
that's lit
you understand she just she hit me with
that like when she watched her so she
hit me with that and i was like
sorry
so yeah they can smell they own you man
people right about that
i remember growing up i'm puerto rican
so the same thing
you can't have none of that in the house
my grandfather was like no it opens the
portal to hell
when you watch scary things or do
so like i know like it was certain like
our things was like you can't have the
weapons and stuff around the house
because that you know that's vital but
so i didn't notice about you know saying
latino culture and it says that so they
feel just by having a horror game that's
the point how devout you are but my
grandfather he was like now there will
be no yo you're not watching the
exorcist in the house no that's not
happening none of that confirmed this
my mom's being neglectful as i think
about it like now i'm like
i was playing anything i wanted
as he stands in the middle of talking
about a bloody mary and candy man
you gotta expound on this please tell me
like it's it's so funny because um
because again like he said it's
you because it's the spirit
thing right and i oh god oh no
i can beat you guys though i can beat
you guys though my cousin was so
religious that she thought uh magic and
yu-gi-oh cards had demons
my cousin she was watching she was
watching charms and that was the the
daughter
she got jumped on for watching charm
like they threw the the the tv out the
window oh no
oh no
not do this on beyonce's internet
because my
lgo led that's sitting in that bedroom
yes that's the good grip
that ain't happening
not over here you flying out after it
okay
you know it's crazy look at the chat
i feel you yo bad people in the chat or
agree with it this is news
it was fighting right so both my wives
are fighting and i run in the living
room
and i separate them both of them gonna
tell you a different story uh
yeah you separated me because you were
trying to save her
the other one you said you separated me
because you was trying to save up cog
know the truth
i was getting them away from each other
because i had so like tv that was in the
living room
[Music]
[Applause]
because this is hilarious
so what movie was that my ex and i went
to go the first conjuring movie
let me
tell you
right now
the whole time i'm sitting here like
this
and i'm watching certain parts
here's the kick for me because i'm a dog
person right
when the dog doesn't even want to go in
the house baby it's time to go
time to go shout out to black people for
recognizing
the
it's time to go i'm the type of person
if i see a spider in my house you can
have it just pay the mortgage
in here yeah for us all movies would end
shorter
[Music]
a white person thing about doing dumb
[ __ ] because there was a haunted like
mansion that no one went to then my
friend ronnie was like let's go explore
like oh
let's go explore
what you should do
i
[Applause]
you know what's it so continue telling
the story and then we're gonna
transition back into the horror stream
we continue um so i i kid you not and
i'm i'm uh uh
i used to go to church heavy
i came home for some water in the cup
started praying and just sprinkling the
water around baby day was not a game it
was not a game for me
this is amazing what's a little i mean
people are thoroughly entertained by you
i think it's a i know it's giving you a
lot of stress but it is clearly
entertaining like people love seeing you
do it i i'm paying money for it
all right so you become a little bit
more desensitized to the horror being
that you uh
stream it often now
like okay like do the jump scares no
longer scare you as much as when you
start it
oh no equally equally yeah no a good
jump scare is going to get you
regardless like i've watched
[Laughter]
i can't play that game vr cause it's
gonna give me a heart attack yeah so i'm
in there and i'm looking around i'm like
oh my god that looked like a ceiling oh
that looked like a floor and it was like
um yo touch the refrigerator i see that
stuff look for real in there shout out
to the playstation vr right so
my girl touched my arm ah man
hilarious do me a favor hustle eddie
mars in there do me a favor um put um
phoenix 443 twitches in there cause they
ask and shout out to he's like yo
everybody got the link to the phoenix
put his information we gotta get it go
go show us the love we gonna get him to
get these horror games popping y'all we
gonna show up a lot of love
a good thing
the good thing about like when it comes
to like good jump scares it's all like
that redirection like they make you
focus something and then something else
happens and that dead space did that
really well but you know let's go ahead
you know uh thank uh thank our guest for
this question you know what's crazy i
put in google i said trivia question for
bioshock they were saying some
off-the-wall stuff that i was even like
they're never going to know about like
what is the total number of audio
diaries across what bioshock you wanted
oh no
so here's what it is uh i will throw
code to the winner of this this one
what year does bioshock 2 take place in
okay
there we go oh you got me
there we go hold on one sec
1952
the fingers is out there you already
know all right and also i'm just really
quick y'all oh thank you hustle you're
the man oh hustle the man i was just
about to put it yo hustling voting
show the co-host of the attic show take
care of phoenix's twitch yeah we gotta
show some love everybody get over there
subscribe to the channel super
entertaining man we got a little bit
more to talk about but uh y'all
answering that question for attic so
that's what's up but yeah i love i love
it i know i'll just gonna say real quick
as far as
all the content that you like streaming
besides obviously the whole right we
love you
um
honestly anything that i
want to have fun with i'm not opposed to
anything outside of fighting games i
think they're oh god
um
like one of my friends wanted me to
stream destiny the other day and i'm
like i said i don't quite know about i'm
just getting back into it you know it
took a good break you know i don't want
to look like a complete noob at the game
yet so
destiny's up next on my uh okay my um my
rotation to stream though i'm gonna
recommend you play tribes
the the the liz
22 got that right related
to it
from the clan that's from the club
1950 it was 1958 no doubt i was off by
six years no doubt i said 1952 right and
i
i don't remember what you said but
it was close
real quick before we go to the next one
king name again
oh um
time stalkers
okay
basically his question is dave a popular
game let me get a popular yeah something
very uh metroid metro metro there you go
all right cool
um i want to talk about in my opinion
one of
your magic moments oh jesus i was saying
the day
lord phoenix
received his game and oscar
from the legendary lord ryan mccaffrey
and made his iconic
podcast unlock debut let's talk about it
how was that day for you
i was nervous
oh i was nervous like i remember we um
so it again i guess it all came like he
hit me up ryan hit me on twitter shout
out to ryan um
and i'm like
are you he's like me yeah are you
trolling me who was that are you really
running you looked and checked to see if
you had the blue marker yeah
you didn't take it
out
i was so confused that i'm like huh so
i'm like oh i would love to do it it
would be great and i have followed ryan
since his oxm days fast so
i'm like double disc in the magazine
days
that that part
so we're going through the show
initially and i'm just sitting here like
okay
so he's like welcome to podcast unlock
episode 511.
and i'm sitting here like it's a
pleasure to be here with you
oh my god
and then i think after i just got into
the motion of it because it's like i'm
not
not used to talking on a mic right
so once i got into it
i was like oh all right i got this i got
it and then just started shooting the
breeze for it and
you brought up the controller
so
xbox hit me up and was like hey we would
love to send you this care package and
you know being very vague about it of
course
so i
come home one day and i'm like oh maybe
this is it and i opened it up and i was
like
i kid you not like i literally
cried because and this is so like
horrible but i cried because i'm like
i've been supporting this brand
for 20 years
and i never wanted like getting into
content creation i i never wanted
anything for free i did it because i
love doing it i absolutely love it all
right and it was the fact that like i've
ride
hard for xbox like i ride hard for
beyonce
stand up
period
[Laughter]
respectfully respect me i appreciate
that
the host be wrong sometime continue
[Music]
but it was just the fact that they sent
me something and
yeah i i
i felt humbled i felt i felt seen you
know what i mean
and
i think that's that was the most
rewarding and interesting thing where in
this space i call it
the boys club because
you see a lot of content creators and i
think you said this on the level one
show who shout out to fame and black
content creator summit we did it was
it's always
the
the cisgender normativity so to speak
where it's like
everybody's clumping up working together
and that
and then throughout the year
let's have this person off of this month
this person offered that month and then
june it was crickets
and
for some of the content creators i
watched i was like
okay that kind of hit me for a little
bit but then i said well you know what
be the change again that you want to see
and represent that person who
is finding their way i'm so happy that
you on the 10k show facts
i love the fact that it's a 10k show now
okay
like when when when cod said that you
was going to be on a screen shot that
mean you've been following each other
for a minute facts we have yeah for a
whole minute and and we gotta give you
your flaws because i'm glad you said
that you know because one thing i do
respect about you is your fearlessness
and you've been very vocal about the
struggle for not just gay content
credits for black gay content creators
and the whole lgbtq you know ia
community and um i'm i'm proud of you
man i'm proud of you in that regard i i
i saw when the the pride package came to
you you know
and it was it was a special moment
because i know what you mean it is any
community
that hasn't been seen and there's no
representation of that
you can't help but not internalize that
hasn't been seen
it's been seen but not acknowledged
exactly acknowledged yes and and the
fact that she was acknowledged in such a
a large format i mean
trust me they send out packages to a
whole lot of people right but it hits
different when it hits you yes
right and it hit you yes you was
acknowledged right and and that means
that you exist in their eyes and that
means you don't know how long they was
looking at your content i mean you don't
know how long they've been checking you
up and sizing you up polls to send you
something to show you their appreciation
for you
you know and that means a lot no
absolutely absolutely so yeah that that
was dope and i i'm glad you brought it
up because i was actually going to bring
it to
you
but yeah it's fine i'll continue i'm
sorry it's your moment
oh no no it's like i said to me is i
never got into it like oh i'm gonna i
want this and i want that i mean i think
that's the wrong reason to get into
content creation to begin with
um but again like like king and like you
said it was just
did they send them out all the time but
it was the fact that they looked at me
and said hey
we want to recognize you you know i
literally said in this chair i picked up
the phone and called a friend of ours
and i just
bawled crying and to me i'll i'll never
forget that moment like ever forget that
moment no salute to phoenix this is fire
no doubt so let me go be respectful of
time but before we let you go you cannot
leave the realm without some questions
sir
okay so i need your top five video games
or franchises of all time we already
know what one is
oh god yes the one with the master chief
the living breathing master chief
um let's get it oh god you put me on the
spot real good um
i want to say the
resident evil series is definitely one
of them
um
[Music]
how do you feel about the new direction
resident evil 1 into
i was a fan of one two three and four
five you lost me six you surely lost me
seven was a good reintroduction yes sir
eight
well i don't believe eight is a bad game
by any stretch of the imagination
um
i felt like eight kind of went in the
same vibe as five to a degree okay where
it didn't feel as scary okay but the dog
was creepy
mr i don't like
the the wild scares is that what the
scares up okay now
i mean but when you seven was crazy
though
i've always felt like resident evil is
what the path it always should be like
you're only going to get those you know
dark corner things like when the virus
first breaks out when people don't
understand what's going on like i always
felt like viruses always mutate so
sooner or later you're going to get
scenarios where it's going to be more
about
eliminating the threat than it is
surviving
my thing was with that seven
what absolutely terrified the mess out
of me mm-hmm
but that it was hillbillies
no this is your real living breathing
massacre
you know why because i i don't care what
nobody said unless you travel the state
you're driving sometimes you travel by
plane
driving you drive you drive through a
rural area in the middle of a damn night
and you tell me when you pull up to that
gas station and they say uh is that a
full unleaded there buddy
that's what they call you kick down
the king
you roll down your window and you look
out and be like uh
whatever
the truth and that is the truth i have
not sir and that's the reason why
there's places up in these hills that
the police won't even the hell yeah
yeah
told me that i said i've never visited
again we got we got halo the iconic we
got resident evil franchise what else we
got legend of zelda oh
i'm a sucker from the skyward sword oh
here we go
to me the best legend of zelda it's not
even up for debate ocarina of time
addict do we co-sign this i'm not
fighting king anymore
did you do it
beat him into submission
oh no
no i thought you like i i i deem it you
know a worthy zelda game but it's still
not one of the best zelda games for you
arcane time's an acceptable answer no
like neither that i actually like
twilight princess a lot like and a lot
of people don't like i felt like it was
the most dark zelda will ever get okay
okay so
got the zelda signs when you're good
yeah you're thinking he's thinking about
it you got those three yeah
i would say the original gears trilogy
[Music]
oh he left out the new year's trilogy
well let i i can elaborate on that let's
go break it down
because to me i felt more connected to
the characters in the first three yeah
um i know
this new trilogy
i'm playing it because i'm a fan of the
franchise i'm not playing it because the
story is gripping me if that means got
you you know i don't think part of the
issue with that is phoenix i think that
they're
they're relying too much on the dad mark
marcus i think like
you know ever he's been in pretty much
all the newer games so it's just like
they're relying on those newer
characters to do something that the
older characters to do something that
the newer characters should be doing
i'm just waiting for microsoft and this
isn't a shot in the this isn't a shot at
them at all but i'm waiting for
microsoft to say
either it's the gears franchise or even
a new one where we're putting a person
of color on the front of it because
looking back at the original gears
trilogy right um
cole who's from baltimore maryland shout
out to him
um he
is the stereotypical black person and
i'm sorry to say we are more than just
comical fodder can i push back a little
bit yeah because we feel about doubt
though that's what i'm going to say
but he's not
what he what he's talking about is he's
not the face okay okay that's different
okay
what i thought they did with that to be
honest with you and that's true with
what you're saying um i thought that
they took the easy role with that
because he shared cohost he was like
co-hosts mm-hmm you understand like you
it is a part where you got to choose you
understand and then you know hey man
yeah sometimes the black guy delilah
she did check her she said well
technically kate is a person of color
yeah
that is true she
yes she is
yeah shout out to hustle cole's daughter
on the cover but that's have busters
though right
to be honest with you i think
like kate is is the only reason i like
the gears franchise really wow you ain't
even like that baby this is bad
no but you know
we're gonna get to this team
like digging into the layers of the
stuff we see exactly i know we're going
with it but i understand exactly what
you're talking about yeah um and it's
something that is prevalent inside uh
movie industry and as a whole oh yeah as
we are trying to you know get to a
different level so i understand what
you're talking about because we talked
about that on the real yeah with uh you
know asante and my boy everyone so
continue your reason in phoenix um
i don't feel connected to the characters
okay right um i i feel like
it's
rehashing old territory for me and
i'm like if
and i'm really trying not to talk bad
about them but
to me i feel as though
take the franchise in an exciting
direction but don't leave out the
fundamental multiplayer basics that made
the game what it is right and i felt
like with
the fifth multiplayer iteration
it's that's not gears to me how did you
feel about tactics
to be fair i only played like 20 minutes
of tech
that's the term style of game yeah
i actually enjoy five in the direction
they went to the only thing i didn't
like about five
was that the third act i didn't like
that act but like the one two and four
and i can't say the third act was like
the worst act known a man but i felt
like that was definitely the lowest
parts of the game but like one two and
four it would i enjoyed every bit of it
especially like two where you're going
around the icy mountains for where
you're because i felt like one and four
felt more like gears
than two and three did
and what's funny is you have people
that's always telling me addict i just
want gears to do something different
solve i just want yours
and then when something like hive
busters comes out they say this is
amazing i'm not talking about you saw
but this is amazing this is awesome i'm
like but high busters is more like the
original gears than the other ones are
still like right i i think for me with
five when they did the open world stuff
it was just it was it seemed very
rudimentary like if you're gonna do it
i'm gonna say something wait a second if
you're gonna do it you do it yeah i mean
so that's what bothered me about that
but it's true i think king king
mentioned horror and i think the first
gears is yeah it's like a horror game i
mean that's where i am
with phoenix though
even though we hijack in his 1-2 i'm
sorry yeah
really hijacking this whole thing but i
do agree it's a great discussion about
the gears franchise because i do feel
what you're saying solve in the sense
that
i was more connected with the characters
of one two three
i love the dom character especially and
then i felt like what you said solved
like they were hard i like gears when
it's scary like i remember
i don't care like one last point i
remember
seeing the berserker for the first time
first time and knowing you're helpless
you got to just survive and watch the
pillars and all of that and then the
second thing that got me is remember
when you would uh you do those stages
with the krill and you have to stay in
the light
and those mechanics was like that i like
fear scary like to me
gears now is they do the most impossible
ridiculous thing and like oh that's a
wednesday
check this out
notice how
i see i thought we was going to have you
for the whole show
know that okay
notice how i've been purposely
extending your state
got to go where he goes now if you if
you haven't noticed
i strategically been placing little
bombs
extrapolate on the title you're right
you you talking about gears and then i
made sure it went long but go ahead
you're ridiculous time get your balls
off and then back and just say something
real quick like in terms of the scary
factor i think it's the same issues we
have with resident evil i feel like
there's a difference between having
a spooky layout it's just not reliving
the same thing over and over again like
the reason i feel like the first
resident evil was particularly scary for
a lot of people in the first gears was
scary for people is because that was the
first iteration like you can't relive
those again not necessarily i don't feel
there's scary moments in the new series
but i don't think that's the issue with
the new ones the issue is the character
development hasn't been part of the
other one
if the character development was on the
part of the other ones i don't think we
would be having and we both said yeah we
both even phoenix's point which we're
going to get back to him is that he
doesn't connect he doesn't he doesn't
connect with that but get here i i see
what you say that's what you said
a
uncharted oh
i would definitely say uncharted little
curveball that's some randy johnson
i just came out with the rko out of
nowhere with
them look did you about to answer this
earlier the other question
favorite console of all time any
generation and why
didn't even get into his history like
that i feel short-changed
hey look next time i'll bring a bottle
of my own
tequila okay okay
favorite console of all nintendo 64.
and why is that
because even today
i will say even today i think the ex the
first party lineup that they had
second to none even on that platform
currently as we speak in my personal
wars
golden eye perfect
legend of zelda ocarina of time majority
mass
a lot of the games because of the n64
like literally reshaped every genre
because of that platform first aid 64.
you know you know what the wildest thing
is
we didn't get your real game in history
and when you come back
i had some real questions we only get
this name and nintendo 64 later we
didn't even know he had more nintendo's
in his life since the person with the
duck hunt on the screen so and they
they're all in my basement actually i
got one of the comments crazy
that's all on mine
that lineup was crazy upgrade man i had
to get to the next i'm done lineup was
crazy and also those wrestling games
though mm-hmm
yeah
wwf no mercy
nobody was seeing me in that game
nobody
go okay let's go
we might have something to say
so can we say
objectively those are arguably the
greatest wrestling games of all time yes
it is i will say that in
wwf smackdown oh yeah
here comes the painting
because i'll be in new york for survivor
series so oh ooh
hollow okay all right see you soon we're
out here god bless
god bless you that's so lovely
tremendous video game history
tremendous person in the limited game
nintendo 64 five seconds ago yes okay
that's okay but uh we gotta salute you
give it your flowers super proud of you
love your fearlessness your courage i
love what you do in the community xbox
ambassador and like you said i think
it's good that people see you know say a
black gay content creator and i love
that you're being celebrated by the
community as well not only just for that
for your talent
you know what i say thank you so much
yeah your talent you are talented it's
not just that that's just one aspect so
salute to you where can the farm people
find you and all that other good stuff
well i'm not going to say anything on
demon time addicts so
that's what you threw out don't joke
um
you can find me on twitter
king phoenix 443 and on twitch phoenix
443 no
doubt because my guy attic came through
with the drip drip yeah he can't do the
drip drips he's cleaned up cleaned up
nice
do me a favor hustle put all of his
stuff in there see the twitch put his
twitter uh i mean i see his twitter put
his twitch in there if you don't mind no
doubt no doubt it uh solver gets her
outros i mean i go to get you out shows
for uh forgetfix
i appreciate you coming along here uh
king we're gonna have to get you king
phoenix uh king i king phoenix and king
man you just call me phoenix
phoenix i appreciate you coming on venus
about to get you back on thank you in
the future it's it's definitely been a a
fun time man uh like i said though uh
we're gonna get you in that chat man
we're gonna let our followers know where
to follow you at man it's definitely
been an interesting show no doubt and
i'll be streaming a horror game tomorrow
whoa what are we doing
what horror games what's going on i
haven't even figured it out it might be
phasma phobia okay
lord solve let's give uh king physics
phoenix man like listen i'm a horror
buff and to see somebody terrified as
they play something that is it's not
their back and be willing to do that for
the people you do for the people you
know they're like
that is absolutely amazing man much love
to you brother man all the success hit
me up in the dm so i could get you that
hoodie my brother oh yeah i gotta get
him
bank will provide he been repping us for
a long time
behind the scenes and it's so cool it's
so cool to see it yeah
we got you the bank and lord king i know
you're very angry that the time was
limited and we will make this right we
will make this right but let's give up
let's give them those flowers man how do
i learn that uh then mini conor i would
have said demolo uh mano uh as i walked
in the room you understand i have two
dominican women so that's where i'm at
within this but uh yes
you get a bigger
at the same time like i said i thought i
thought i had you for the whole day i
was trying to get out uh uh king phoenix
old school style you know you know messy
phoenix
yes sir you saw how i set it up in the
beginning but also um i wanted to let
you know that you was welcome here yeah
you know and i'm so happy that is the
10k show that she was a part of you know
um because that's a milestone in in our
history
and you're part of that yes so when
people look at the 10k show
they're gonna see you there
so nobody would ever know the song that
i put on in the background
and yo shout out to wifey cause last
night i was playing i was gonna buck
bananas um
i was playing it last night
and i said i'm playing this tomorrow
because she she knew about you coming on
cause i was talking about you for at
least four days
right so i said um i'm playing this
tomorrow you know as my intro coming in
and
she was like is that too much i said
hell no they ain't too much that's lit
right there
oh your phoenix is late they just lit
when you played it i showed her your
videos she was like
that crap
listen uh it's so hot i'm so happy that
you're here and i appreciate you and and
thank you for coming through and sharing
your time with us i thought i was going
to have you through to the messy part
because i'm about to get really messy
but um
see you soon brother
[Music]
thank you all so much for having me on
it it really means a lot you know super
super proud of you we're gonna again
we'll do it again and again we got it's
so cool like i said to see your journey
i remember you from back in the day
shout out to all other content creators
who we have mutual friends andrew
alliance paris you know a lot of people
fame you know what i'm saying like you
know it's just so cool you know and and
finally get get this happening and we
will do it again but enjoy your sundays
and uh we will be back in the realm of
course you already listen yeah so we
gotta get some destiny oh for sure
[Music]
for a moment we got vogelskrieg remember
for 11 months lord go thank you sir
congrats on the 10k you'll be at the
100k mark before you know it
thank you my brother then we have
cyanodex member for two months
uh welcome to the welcome to rum again
and we got doomy remember
once
congrats to the iop for 10k 10 months is
as a member happens to be a milestone
for you all super proud of you the
avengers of podcast thank you no doubt
salute
we have brian mota welcome to the real
put the crest in the chat for the new
member brian malta thank you sir no
doubt and we have always cola two dollar
super chat uh
that means ten thousand wonderful
keep up the great work fantastic
then we have michael patton five dollar
super chat oh hell the iop the first ten
thousand salute from saint louis is it
just me or does the sony fanboys get
quiet when halo infinite flights happen
yeah
yeah there we go big cloud gaming five
dollars on the chat welcome to the 10k
club
mad love so my brother's next stop is
20k
man he go support him man he's got a
huge guest coming up he got yo he got
agent 47
from him
iconic voice in the game make sure y'all
go to big cloud i believe it's this
thursday correct me from wrong big cloud
but um yeah salute to you bro that's
that's a that's a huge get hell yeah
we got the brother ever born saga 10
super chat
salute to the lords just dropping to say
congrats on the 10k milestone 100k here
we come thank you brother come out the
godzilla yes hold me i'm
okay so we got to figure something out
yeah we'll see all right shout out
man that's the homie what's up what else
we got then we got brian mota once again
10 super chat i just wanted to thank the
lord for keeping me sane during the very
tough time between jobs recently i
sincerely appreciate it salute to you
all thank you brother thank you thank
you anything to make people smile man
absolutely
then we have the otaku fix five dollars
with the chat congrats on the 10k fellas
thank you my brother
taco
then we got suicide kings member for 11
months tcl sent me candy
can't get this smoke
happy 10k day gentlemen well deserved
thank you
then we got brett bingham ten dollar
super chat
uh old dance move said old days who says
sony would be making more larger studio
acquisitions my only concern with p
perfect dark development is if sony by
square enix and perfect dark development
is ruined or at least disrupted okay if
you're looking at the tea leaves uh
who's buying a square
footage
yeah we have heard it from here firestar
66 uh member for two months shout out to
it's first i'll put the crush in the
chat oh and he says
congrats on the 10k thank you so much
brother then we got big cloud gaming
remember for seven months old bronze
this man david had me dying right now
[Music]
there we go oh no it's alex five dollars
alex
that's kind of crazy salute that's the
homie he's like oh no
xbox fan boys are going to be in
shambles
because alex be careful because they was
calling you on
an xbox fanboy before they thought you
was coming at playstation okay so you
got some oh i wonder what this topic
gonna be
infinite not running correctly on pc
yeah he go away shout out shout out to
alex he does i quote tweeted this
morning he said we made it again
listen shout out to him though i i
support him because for the pc ports we
need those on paul we need those on paul
so i definitely will check that out
diminish them
diminish them make them play someplace
else
you're ridiculous there we go aaron jf94
two dollar super chat welcome to the
guest mr name name is king phoenix sir
follow me all the links are in the chat
let me grab that
then we got sika mikaniko
yeah xbox era
my lords a heart congratulations on the
big 10k and army to defend the realm
well deserved very well
thank you very much
then we got boonty
the original don donna you're fair two
months enough respect
no distance
let's
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
remember the house in the corner the
house in the corner that had like the
the the the foliage growing over here
right you did a little bit
all right
here we go run b five dollars with the
chat wow 10k happy for the iron lords
thank you my brother and uh we are
caught up okay okay cool guys let's get
into it actually before we get into it
we do have last week's poll results are
in and the people have spoken with rumor
swirling of a potential major xbox
acquisition happening soon which of
these entities do you want microsoft to
pursue
the winner of an extremely close
four-way poll
eeking out the victory
only 30
of the vote
the warner brothers group
coming in at second place super close 28
was take two interactive in third place
another super close vote 24 with sega
and then last place with 16 of the vote
was i don't care but if none of these
acquisitions happens the xbox insider
community gonna get this smoke shout out
to all those
and clearly nothing happened so
no south yeah you you were you want to i
think you were the water brothers train
i believe that warner brothers is the
one that makes the most okay right
it's just a matter of like i know you
guys are arguing about the ip but i do
think the studios there are excellent at
what they do so given the chance to make
new ip i think they would be fantastic
as well
obviously obviously batman you know
batman is back
don't waste the money you know
you want to get a couple more super
chats right i see forte pulled up come
on
great things happen to great people this
milestone was a long time coming 10k is
only the beginning i love you guys and
everything you've done for the community
hashtag strength and love hashtag that's
my family
brother i miss you i feel like i've been
talking to you in a while but so busy
always loved being oh yeah i still got
to send him some image yeah yeah she did
yeah yeah bro he's he's such a good dude
man that's my definitely bro
the lord's on 10k lord cog did you catch
sm-11
chess versus easy to block camp there yo
that's battle rap talk and the dinner no
yes folks yeah that's battle right shout
out to b he'd be on his back on his
square yeah yeah that was that was
legendary yes i did summer madness 11
battle right we're gonna work on trying
to get some
i ain't gonna suppose we're gonna work
on some people in the community don't
know people let's just say that
they'll definitely salute to that so uh
we all good let's get into our lady fox
fire with the two dollar super chat
congratulations big fan girl here well
deserved absolutely foxy
throw the crest up and all that oh
actually one last thing i have to do
because i've been doing my job and
slacking shout out to david hot right
this morning he got that classic
pullover he says love the show guys it's
the lord's day seeing that drip you know
fantastic more than that but
let me ask a question real quick sure
let's go so this is for code in the chat
yes what is the name of metroid's home
planet the metro its own planet okay
metroid's whole planet y'all insidious
i could get something get them codes up
get that get that work
you know what i'm saying so while that's
going on lord sav you are up
am i i thought it was you well it was
the attic was the attic this yeah this
is addict i believe
yeah yeah well no we i thought we're
doing uh crystal d first
[Music]
for
[Music]
so yeah um i
probably look about maybe four maybe
five hours into cana bridges spirits uh
new third-person
uh kind of action-adventure game from
amber labs this is their first outing um
and these guys were primarily sort of uh
like cgi artists yeah
animation studio um and this is their
first game and i have to say man for
being a not even for being a first
outing the game is is gorgeous and they
got a lot of things right is it 60
frames or 30 there's there's a 30 frames
uh well no there's
i'm playing at like 1440 whatever 60 um
oh checkerboard with checkerboard
exactly he's trying to be he's trying to
have been too many sort of funky things
happening with pc ports these days so
i'm just like let me just get the
playstation first okay okay um so yeah
it runs beautifully i think it has a
digital you bought it hardcore digital
they always buy everything you put your
credit card on there well you remember i
don't i don't have i don't have the
herniated playstation i have only
digital you can use your you can use
your paypal too king oh i don't know
you don't have it
i learned a long time ago you put that
buffer in between a station network and
you're a bodyguard
you would be lying that you don't trust
the security i don't get a big homie
brother
bro like you know
because you're buying something you just
don't know big homie gotta check that
out
you know when you go to the supermarket
and you look in your bag to make sure
your receipt match what you got you're
ridiculous all right i love how he
hijacked this whole situation
let me literally hijack this about
playstation security but it's not about
the game
he's not wrong though
because i need to be your phone you need
to be a phone good at it
also if you're in the chat i want you to
put in the chat again for the next
trivia keep going no doubt continue so
let's get into it so yeah so the game
the game is a third person character
action game where you play as kana um
and she's basically a spirit guide who
is tasked with sort of
um helping spirits that can't pass on to
the next sort of
life because they hope they're holding
on to
some like traumas or tragedies that
happen in their lives so what happens
she's an exorcist she basically is a
necessity she is
you look at it and it looks it's very
cartoony looking right it's like a like
a cartoon looks like a pixar movie
whatever the case may be but the themes
are pretty heavy oh and there's some
moments there's some moments that are
like oh wow okay
yeah so um so yeah she's tasked with
with with sort of helping these wayward
spirits that can't find their way to the
other side and in the process of doing
that they've sort of uh infected the air
the world around them so she has to
clear she has to clean out that
infection and
she does this with the help of these
cute little uh these cute little
whatever they're like little uh churros
yeah and cherubs they're called the rock
though
they're the names of rocks the rocks how
cute they go around like that
so so basically what they do they i
guess they're so pure that they can sort
of absorb the evil okay and sort of hold
it down while kana cleanses it right so
that's kind of the dynamic between her
and the rod um so like i said before the
game is absolutely gorgeous i think they
have a 30 fps mode yeah they have a 30
fps mode or something that's shooting
for 60 it doesn't quite hit it and then
they have the the checkerboard mode
which runs beautifully at 60. okay
on the playstation
yeah
i guess
ridiculous
i would not confirm it tonight
let me ask you this from a graphical
fidelity standpoint because we know how
like ratchet and clank is really yes
moving out here so like let's do a
little i know
like
graphical fidelity king oh okay i was
just asking questions i'm just i need to
be informed yeah you will be informed
um
for being a small studio
everything looks pristine and crisp and
and beautiful there's this instances
where there's lighting you give that
caveat what i don't know because it's
just a fabulous lesson it is their first
okay first go around yeah
alert
thank you
[Applause]
so yeah when you compare it to like a
ratchet and clank has a lot of effects
going on in the background like right
there's moments when you like you go
into the foliage and the foliage is
going to move around your stuff like
that this ain't that
it's gorgeous there's gorgeous moments
of lighting and stuff like that it runs
well but you could tell like the like
the forest the trees don't move around
you don't see the leave the foley it's
just not that she doesn't have this
crazy sort of interaction with the world
around her right so it it is sort of
stagnant in that way but it is pretty
it's very pretty that's areas that they
can improve on for the expert oh for
sure the xbox version not the sequel the
xbox person
yo make sure you make those bushes move
yeah they gotta move better
let me go ahead and ask this next
question you guys uh uh
go ahead and thank one of the members he
he he put this on you i didn't even look
this up he wants a halo trivia so you
know that's his fault because i'm not
the person you asked for a halo trivia
with what
what is what did noble 6 do before he
joined the the um
the team in reach what was what did he
do all right there you go continue so
foliage now that's solve um pixels it
says the foliage does move uh maybe no
it doesn't i don't i don't really really
does that in chicken boy move no it's
like all jokes aside
when i was watching like streams of it
and stuff the only thing that i could
tell that like i could nitpick on
was like it would be like it looked like
it would be windy in the game yeah but
the trees aren't moving at all the trees
aren't moving like this or maybe there
are instances where like there's foliage
that moves a little bit but it isn't
something you could tell the foliage as
a whole isn't interactable the way it is
they wasn't using speed tree they didn't
they didn't ask microsoft could they use
that middleware um
the game has a feel
like like old character action games it
really does it has that feeling of i was
a big mark of cree fan on the
playstation 2.
absolutely um like art style-wise it
does feel that way in that it's kind of
linear right you have this game has like
a hub world where it seems like you're
gonna all your big main missions are
gonna come out of that hub world um
and so far like the story seems pretty
cool where it's the first some of the
first people that you meet these these
spirits are children and they need your
help with something um and that's where
i was talking about before where it
seems like there are moments in this
game we have some like some little
poignant things that you know you just
you didn't expect when you go into
playing this game
um
so yeah it's it's it definitely it looks
like it's for kids but not oh so
yeah right and again like most kids
movies right they take the subject
matter and try to try to envelop it
digestible for smaller kids but an adult
can take away certain things from it as
well
so uh when it comes to the combat though
the combat is pretty straightforward
not super in depth but what it does is
like basically she has
she has uh what you call it uh melee
moves that she has where staff which is
basically um you do it just like like
like souls where the the attacks are on
the triggers right so she has a light
attack and a and uh and a heavy attack
okay and that basically can be upgraded
throughout the game the skill tree isn't
super elaborate it's only a couple of
really skills anyway that i can see from
where i play to to this point right um
it's not super elaborate but it does you
know it feels good it feels snappy it's
not it's not deep combat by any stretch
of the imagination and there are certain
things you could do so
when it comes to the rock the rot can
also help you sort of because
the right they're they're scared right
they're generally scared right okay so
what happens is when you fight in combat
with melee
it gives them courage to be like yeah
let's join them hold on oh they want
jump dudes with your man
yeah exactly so where you was when you
beat up on somebody and they feel you're
doing wonderful they're like all right
let's go in and help cana so they're
these moves oh they talking dude
but when an enemy comes out on the
screen and they don't have their courage
up they're going high they're like no no
no no
but they wait for you to get him off his
back exactly exactly yeah
you know you beat up a couple of little
minions or whatever and then they get
their courage up they can encourage them
so then what happens is that you'll see
like a little icon puppet that says use
the rod and the rod you can either
so you can you can expand your move set
with the rock where they you can
actually uh use the rod as a weapon like
like there's like a hammer type like
weapon that they they come together in
like this gel okay and then they become
sort of weaponized so you can do crazy
little things with them um i've only up
to like i'm only up to like the third
power or whatever but it's pretty cool
um so that in addition to the um
the melee combat gives a you know it's
it's not exactly you know like a dark
souls deep game in that regard but it
gives you enough for this type of game
another thing that she has a disposal is
that basically the lore indicates that
the people that die in this game what
they do is that
the the
the villagers sort of build masks sort
of in their honor and the masks sort of
uh allow them
the mass is kind of the embodiment of
going from ashes to ash's dust to dust
so when the mass disintegrates
completely it's indicative that the soul
has been able to move on to the other
side so uh you you're able to use these
masks and when you put the mask on it's
sort of one at first it lets you see the
memories of the specific spirit that
you're trying to help and try to
understand why they're not able to move
on and then secondly it also gives you
like a second site that allows you to
see like secrets and whatnot in the
environment in order to be able to
traverse because sometimes it's not
although it's linear it's not
necessarily super good about telling you
what the next next specific objective is
um not that you'll get lost anything
like that but this kind of you put on
the mask and it's like oh this is
highlighted this is highlighted this is
highlighted
so um i mean so far again i'm only four
or five hours in everything that i've
seen in the game is like i cannot i'm
enjoying it i like the fact that it
doesn't try to do too much yeah
because it doesn't try to do two it
doesn't you know how it games
what was the game
you know what it makes me think about
biomuting we're buying
okay biomutant is that thing where it's
like the concept when we saw the tan
that looks crazy and in execution they
got part of that right but it seemed
like they tried to do so much with a
team that's relatively small that it did
the things they should have focused on
and really made the core of that game
get lost in them just trying to give you
so much stuff to do in terms of the
combat in terms of the upgrades it was
just too much they should have whittled
it down a little bit and i think this
they get it right in that it's not too
much and there's there's definitely a
next step to be had here with their next
game but as of
as as a throwback that makes me you know
think about games like marco creed and
even the old character platformers like
your jack and daxters and stuff like
that it has that sort of feel right um
you know it's it's it's really good it's
really good my question before i pass
off the attic is that um
like for their first joint like do you
see like yo they they got one that yeah
not everything's perfect but it's so
punching above its weight that really
the foundation is there for like a
sequel they could really expound upon it
the foundation is absolutely there like
they have the chops in terms of creating
beautiful worlds and character
animations and like uh when you look at
the facial animations and stuff like
that you know that that is their forte
that is what they do
so with a bigger budget maybe a bigger
team next time around
them expanding upon that and doing the
things we were talking about like the
entire world being full open world maybe
and everything being interactable like
stuff like that
i know that there's there's definitely a
step to be had and i know they know what
that step is to take this if they want
to continue with this franchise or
whatever the next thing they do is it's
definitely going to be a step above this
100 so whatev whatever they really got
their feet wet with this
um
and even like the storytelling stuff the
stuff that you may not expect like it's
like oh you know this is their first
time out stories kind of whatever the
story is kind of boilerplate but like i
said those moments of kind of the
poignancy with like you know emotional
issues and stuff like that and then
anything having to do with spirits that
are unable to pass on because there's
trauma and tragedy that they can't get
over yeah that's a deep subject yeah
absolutely
and so far what i've seen it handles it
well
so
i think really again i'm
anybody who has the opportunity to play
this game play this game now but i'm
really excited for what they can do in
the future sounds like a kitty version
of the medium
yeah kittier
face but i'm gonna ask did he play the
medium yes i did i didn't meet him
no i was like bored
yeah did you finish it did you yes sir
yes oh that's good that's great okay
hold on before this gets deleted by
before this gets deleted there's
somebody arguing about working in the
chat about dark souls i don't know if
they're talking to me or they're calling
somebody else a [ __ ]
i don't i i sure did not say dark souls
is repetitive or whatever yeah continue
anyway goodbye yeah
like you were saying before we get the
kick as far as um you're feeling on
kenna
the gameplay
it didn't look real in depth is there
more depth than it looks solved it just
looked like you pressed a button attack
put up a berry when they hit you press
button
okay so this is the thing that's kind of
there's a thing okay no no it's been
it's been in contention the past couple
of days because some people are like yo
this game is kind of difficult
and you know like i said this a while
back i play everything on on heart and
then you know
and then from there so on hard i would
say
the enemies the enemies feel a little
more spongy and again they have some
tactics to them
but it it's not easy it's not
necessarily easy and there's things you
like you have a parry and they really
want you to use that parry because the
parry uh you know you're gonna have
enemies that come out with shields and i
think so in terms of the variety you
have in the combat itself it's it's kind
of limited like i said your your skill
tree is not crazy
now what happens is as you progress in
the game even at this short period of
time four or five hours in you start
seeing different enemies that force you
to use those moves in different ways
that make it more intriguing so it's
more about i'm i'm excited to see what
comes later because um again there's
there's been some talk about this online
like this game is hard um i want to see
what happens with these enemies a little
bit later on because apparently it just
seems that the variety of enemies sort
of forces you to play differently thus
making the combat more engaging okay but
as in terms of your loadout stuff
it's it's very it's limited it's it's
the rock moves and it's the it's the the
the watchmaker it's the rock moves and
it's yeah i don't like the way you got
stuff
i don't like the way he said
that was like the build-up on character
development is there any type of like
progressive when you want to like
upgrade abilities or is it like pretty
much you just get a new ability no you
um you're going to unlock whatever the
currency is right there's a few
different type of currencies there's
like uh
there's like a
a currency that seems like diamonds or
whatever i didn't know what it's called
that allows you to buy you can buy
little hats for your rocks
there's also xp like currency that you
spend on upgrading your move so yeah
that's the you spend that on upgrading
your melee moves oh and she also has i'm
sorry she also has um
like like a
distance move she does have moves that
you can use at a distance as well with
the like with the like a bow and arrow
type
yeah delilah said when you get the
second weapon it opens up it opens up
more can i distance myself from the game
you're ridiculous
continue so there's no game like this
that you like like character action game
because i thought you would like this
one
one thing people were making zelda
comparisons and zelda comparisons in the
sense to o zelda right um in that there
is it's like a hub world because
you're disgusting no no
done with you but why is that so
appalling to you delilah said she thinks
she would like it
i think you would we think i think i'm
surprised you didn't get on this one
yeah there's something about it he saw
from the beginning
let's get to the opposite real quick
like what was it about it that you it
didn't draw you i'm curious i i don't
know just like
when i was seeing the game play on terms
like the combat
it didn't look very engaging
it looked like just like when i played
combat like that
i wanted to have like a cost meaner and
and what i was seeing it didn't feel
like that like i wanted like when i play
any type of game play like that i want
to be able to build the build i want to
build i want to be able to to play the
game how i want to play and i kid you
not i went through like eight different
streams because i was debating if i
wanted to play it and they all playing
the game the same way almost like every
single one of them so
yeah it's it's one of those things like
you when you you know like any game
right when you have you can have a
million moves but you're going to stick
to the ones that work for you right see
but they're more more ability to be more
diverse and yeah everything should be an
option and that's why i don't like cert
that's why when people complain about
like halo with with the guns i'm like i
don't want to just use the br i want to
have a variety of options when i'm
playing this game and on there i'm
seeing people play kinah exactly the
same way
okay and i and i think
again that you know it's a feature creep
thing where i think they were like for
the sequel
yeah it's funny with attic right now
it's hilarious
because
it didn't look engaging finally plays it
oh damn i'm sorry i didn't give it a
chance
daniel alex real thoughts cause it's
forty dollars for early access until
game pass
anyway let's get kicking in real quick
man okay yeah clearly you have thoughts
about the performance of this game but
uh about the game itself like did it not
interest
i knew it was gonna be what it's gonna
be on the playstation's underpowered you
know
so i know you're gonna have 1440p uh for
the 30 frames per second i knew he's
gonna have 1080p for the checkerboard it
up to the limit
outside of the performance sir no i mean
performance is a lot hold on okay
i do apologize for your guys that don't
understand i pay a lot for my television
i mean my joint don't come up off the
floor the only thing i saw that looked
weird
um king when i was playing it's like i
said like
like because i was watching a kid smooth
play and like he would go through like
the foliage and stuff and like he
wouldn't move at all the trees in the
background
that's not like a huge deal but in terms
of this pixar kind of
kind of details that they're having 64.
like the
the it to me like the way they design
the world
those trees not moving is a big deal to
me but we got to clarify
frames y'all there is a 60 frames
at a lower resolution stop pointing your
fingers like y'all talking about there
is a 60 frames a second king i'm telling
you yeah the lower resolution
why are you championing that like
why would you raise your hand put your
hand down
don't be recognized christopher says the
trees do move the trees
don't make me bring up a youtube video
chris parker because i will i i will you
know
his trees don't move and he just said
and if they move it's very light like
you can't tell but like when you're it
like you're in a forward a forest and
you feel like you feel like it's windy
here you know what i'm saying but then
you look around
so the trees is moving this is the deal
this is the reason song that these two
can't cop the game no this is
a rant about the combat like okay no no
i get it you're right you're right
you're right about that
i was born for kick my bad that was both
of the kicks yes listen when i saw the
police station joined i was like oh that
was one of the ones i was looking at
okay police station no the playstation
the police station so when i saw that
the playstation uh uh what was it the
the indie fest whatever the hell you had
going on
you know um the multi-platform uh
display unit that they was doing um
highlighting all the xbox games that
will come out the trucking demo now for
free for a fee um
i saw him and i was like okay that's
cool and then when i heard that it's
coming out on xbox i was like oh shout
out to game pass
you know save me some money let y'all
demo without the non-treaty moving and
then with digital foundry
it may not come the game faster yo
listen i don't care i would come out
the xbox slow-mo in the chat said is
trees not moving
it wouldn't be an issue if they didn't
choose the art direction they chose they
chose this game to look gorgeous this
game to be very immersive but then
you're in this forest and nothing's
moving
all right i'm sorry i mentioned this
[Laughter]
the game still looks absolutely gorgeous
there are moments when lightning strikes
and and it's pitch black dark
so we can get lightning strikes but we
can't
listen listen first i'm not okay see
y'all never even got to my whole real
opinion let's go yeah cause all i can
hear about performance
did it come out on pc yes yes
okay so now that we can talk about the
higher fidelity uh unit all right so now
that we talk about 4k uh 60 frames per
second stuff like that um i think that
stuff is important with games like this
being that i knew that they came from a
background of animation yes and to get
off this uh level of detail in a game is
phenomenal especially your first try if
you would have told me in the beginning
that this was the first game that they
was making i wouldn't have believed you
because i saw the you know the level of
um
of detail in the world it looked rich
and then
when you tell me that you know this is
on next generation consoles and you know
pc
that's letting me know that this the the
tools that they're using is so robust
that they can extrapolate this stuff out
of a first time studios game um you know
so it's good that they have a background
in animation um they need to work on the
trees with the animation but
that's me being petty yes but again i
thought it was a it was a nice something
for you know playstation owners to have
during the holidays you know it's gonna
be a little bit dry but they got they
got something to play you know how big
this is you know how big this studio is
i think like seven people fourteen oh
wow okay oh man they needed to hire two
more people for an hour oh my god yo
shout out to slow mo backslash
he said it's about eight to nine hours
in the game
he said i didn't notice the trees didn't
move until someone pointed out to me i
was too busy taking screenshots at the
beautiful
environment
they're still they're still you're not
i'm not saying that the tree thing is
such a drastic thing i'm saying for the
level of detail that went into this game
in terms of how it looks how it feels
the way it's like really you know
glowing vibrant but then you look in the
back nothing's moving you're supposed to
be in a forest but there's literally
i'm not saying it's dead it doesn't feel
dead but i'm just like it doesn't feel a
lot the game doesn't fit well this is
the thing i think as as in people as
people who who focus on animation
i'm sure that was one of the first
things on the table so whatever the
conversation around that was i'm sure
that the fact that they had to be like
we have to roll back on this
probably bothered them a minute let me
ask you a question um sovereign can't
how many of those little um rots can you
have on the screen at one time oh
there's like a hundred of them
or something like that
okay this is that's the caveat right
there if at any point in time you're
going to have the the the
enemies
the rod that could be a hundred of these
little dudes plus
the protagonist there and the world
you're going to have to scale back
certain things especially for a
first-time studio so maybe they were
sitting and it was like yo we got to
take the animation out of the trees
because we dropped the performance
so we got it
it's their first goal and i i respect
their first goal i'm just pointing out
that you know that the trees bother me
now is it like a deal breaker no but you
know in terms like i think it
disappointed me the most because how
beautiful the game
it looks like it's like it kind of gave
me like a little bit more of a mature
witcher vibe like the way that
everything feels so alive
but like you know it just disappoint me
when i'm looking at it it just felt so
dead and alive at the same time and i
think obviously it's a small studio and
this is something they could build off
of and they did way more with way other
people are done with way more exactly
but i'm getting my flowers but if one of
you pointed out no i know that what
watches this eventually and they're like
yo that dude didn't like the trees fix
your trees in the season yeah but at the
same time
they were in the budget yeah i don't
know you don't you don't know what you
don't know what's going on they delayed
it what once at least once they delayed
it right yeah
you know like like any dev studio i'm
sure they would have liked to had a
limited time to work on this and put out
the exact product they wanted to and you
know it has to fit within a certain time
sony
[Laughter]
let's see if his level is in there uh
what's up man
yeah yeah yeah what's up brother he's in
a building what's going on bro hey they
out here being extra tough i feel bj you
have played this game
thumbnails on fire sir after you have to
give your thumbnails on fleek i really
like what you're doing out there so tell
us about keith how you liking it man
yeah shout out to the dude who made that
thumbnail because you know i'm not
talented like that in the art space
um
definitely not talented in that way
um
so yeah i'm actually like i'm
10 hours into kane it's about 15 hours
i'm at the last section of the game
um so i'm pretty much at at the end at
this point nice and i i didn't expect
this much from this game like at first
when you start out yeah it seems like
it's going to be one of those very
simplistic games where
it's attack
it's light attack heavy attack you block
that that's what what i thought it was
going to be and i was like yeah this
simply you know and i didn't expect much
gameplay-wise from uh from
a studio that really doesn't have a long
resume and their own their resume is
just complete animation so i'm like yeah
right you know my i thought this game
was probably gonna get you know i
predicted like maybe a 70 meter critic
or something because i was like yeah the
gameplay is going to be lacking
currently sitting at 81. yeah
and the further you get in the game
you're like
like these guys
these guys did their thing like they i
don't know if they brought in a
specialist
um to help them with the gameplay but
they're farther
hey man
that's what we're doing around
everybody needs some help
here in a second after bg gets his bars
off you're gonna have to go to facebook
cog and pull up this tweet because
christopher trying to comfort me on
twitter all right
because i ain't feeling this this
remarks you saying the christian heart
know that you better leave the chat
because i'm about to roast you
let's get vg's vlogs
yeah but it's just like there's not a
huge skill tree um i think there's a
total of 12 skills you can unlock and
then there's like three more skills that
specifically are rot abilities um so the
skill tree is not it's not huge at all
especially when we play other games like
you know it could take you forever to
unlock the skill tree and by the time
you finish the game you're you're like
maybe halfway through the skill tree
right right so the skill tree is not
expansive so you can see
their limitations
maybe budget wise or gameplay
mechanic-wise in how small the skill
tree is but they they do so much
with that small skilled small skill tree
that you don't really feel like it's
lacking that much okay right um the the
platforming is well done uh they're
small like environmental puzzles nothing
too crazy
um
but just the way the create the creative
ways that they use um that they create
that they do the level design even with
their limitations
is very impressive the enemy variety um
the bosses yeah i'm surprised there was
that many bosses in the game wow um this
sounds like a good game
you're going to be you're going to be
surprised because i think in each
section there's there's like one main
boss in each section and there's a whole
then there's a bunch of i don't even
want to call them mini bosses because
they're like almost just as challenging
as the main boss so they'll put like
three or four mini bosses and then
there's like one main boss in each
section and it's just like yeah like
people are saying it's not easy
because
the like the timing on the parry that
you know when you block it's a very
small window
and you have to get that that timing
down and people's first
people's first boss is when they're
gonna have the hardest time that you may
have seen that because you're not
expecting it like the
the spike in difficulty it you know it
it kind of hits you suddenly at that
first boss and like this it wasn't like
this before
they didn't prepare for it no
doubt but yeah the games the game's
really you know what is
uh
the negatives i would say that
it's it's the fact that
you can see their limitations as a
as
as kind of like rookies right um that
the game play isn't like i said it does
get bet better the further you go but
it's not that deep you know the game
play isn't that deep you can there are
different abilities that you get through
you get on your journey and you learn to
combine them and there are really cool
combinations
um but the gameplay isn't super deep i
will say that as far as like listen i
don't know where this
i don't know this narrative of
moving bushes came yeah let's get let's
see let's get the tree listen listen
when dudes is analyzing fruit
nothing ain't nothing off the table
they got it the chat's got to see what
i'm talking about
i mean i can read it i'm not glorifying
foolishness at the end of the day
he didn't even say the video that he
posted he didn't even say your name
he tweeted me oh well he stopped you but
and when i'm looking at the tweet your
name's not in the tweet so no he tweeted
me and king like specifically
i just got on twitter one day and people
were shooting fruits and walking through
bush
go
go on facebook i'm about to put it in
the chat yeah yeah basically oh okay so
he tried it yet i need them these he
said um seems like the foliage is moving
to me i need some people to see that he
has a video of um you know keena using
like a spirit bomb thing and lo or
foliage moving around her so
if you look at it like look in the
background like nothing's moving in the
background nothing's even slightly
moving in the background and the wind
does like that how is it that it's it's
blowing leaves but the trees aren't
blowing moving see i got to be real with
you about this right let's go and tree
gate pushes gate i i do so i'm
i would say i'm a i'm very like
i'm a very visual person but as far as
like i guess environmental physics i'm
not like
i'm not like super anal about it right
visuals yes but like environmental
physics like oh if this doesn't move
i'll be real with you i'm i'm too i'm
too much into the game right like
probably notice too much of that i will
notice like imperfections though yeah
right but i gotta say when you play in
this game
i think uh
slo-mo said it bro you don't notice yeah
i'm b-roll with you
watching it that's the first thing i
noticed it looks watchable see butcher
but what have you done
if you play it you're gonna see it if
you're looking at what i'm saying sit
here act like we don't pick apart things
all the time but i say yo why
why is it why is our wind blowing but
the trees ain't moving i'm telling you
i'm telling you when you play it you're
not gonna notice you you watched it you
have you haven't played it yet
so when you watch it you looking at all
this other bro i i
i didn't know until y'all mentioned it
i got over it real quick like the moment
bg right in the beginning when she's
going through the caves and she walks
out of the cave and it there's the
lightning strike
and when you see that for the first time
you're like oh okay they got it
because
you don't know you like the video game
before i think you don't notice it
because the environment like the
atmosphere is so right right like
nothing's moving but you walk into an
area where it's raining and it literally
looks like just how it like i don't know
if y'all seen frozen when the ship was
wrecked and it was like this
thunderstorm and everything like that it
looked like that so you don't notice
nothing's really moving because the
atmosphere is done is just done so well
that's i would have noticed that easy
easy
i'm like
i can't sit here and be immersed in
something with all this one going on and
i'm looking at the screen and nothing's
moving besides a little bit of grass
besides
you always come from people that say but
have you played it
game play on xbox right that's gameplay
i would have been telling you i'm ray
charles
respect to your account respect to that
i'm gonna keep i'm gonna keep it funky
uh i just like trolling these guys like
i just really do
anything i'm to be like a pit bull and
i'm going to grab this
back of a meat truck and i'm going to
shake the hell out of it so these dudes
is talking about oh king but the bushes
move not on your tcle
i think we've exhausted this enough
without shout out to bg because i
definitely want to be on yo i'm gonna be
on your neck bg like well let's some
detail you say on twitter man i'ma bring
up this quote someone
sniff this out of the podcast that way
when when bg wants to complain anything
about any form of detail in the game
i'ma toss this on twitter i i will
absolutely i will absolutely complain
about you know visuals and art style but
physics ain't really something like you
know people
i didn't say it was important i said
it's not something people have like seen
me historically complain about in my on
my
you know i haven't seen anything about
this bush's thing so when it was talked
about i i see all right
my whole job here is to give
entertainment to somebody who's having a
bad day i feel that right so what i'm
supposed to do right now is make you try
i'm trying to make you piss your pants
while you're waiting
real quick go to the iop chat and click
that tweet
let me say one thing let me say one
thing you you we're at a time where
developers have been sacrificing facts
uh physics for visuals for a while like
i remember i remember i saw a you know
what you know a game has really good
physics that that like no modern game
probably even rivals far cry
r cry2 there's there's no modern game
that touches the physics of fundraising
because development
everything you know
because you can't advertise and show off
physics like that in the matter
it's because of people in this podcast
in this chat saying not a big deal
that's all you know what do you do
and people laugh at this one but just
cards
though yeah listen
those things those games do things with
physics that no triple a game while the
triple a game that is not considered
sort of a a side thing
does
like are you playing just cars
[Laughter]
we're gonna be playing in a month nobody
uh
of physics and and how they layered it
was absolutely immense for the stuff
that they did um and and that it was
across the board so on every console
that level of physics was represented
all the way through but we're we're
talking apples and oranges we're talking
about bushes and fruit um where we're
i'm trolling you dudes so let me tell
you something let me tell you when you
took the bait christopher you fell for
it you fell for the banana in the tail
pipe you ran to twitter to show me
something i really didn't care about it
you really did it so it's a victory for
me you yelling out you need knees
with no knees i took your knees when you
fell for the bait stop falling for the
banana in the tailpipe
maybe the
the big reason is like
a lot of games that has the type of art
style they like the environment they
really
really make sure what it is i know what
you're saying what it is everything
looks so beautiful so when you saw any
little difference it'll stand out more
because the the majority of the picture
what you're saying it's just like when i
see the game and every like the
environment the the because the sound in
this game is good too i like the sound
yeah are you just sitting here looking
at you see the wind going around i'm
like wait those trees aren't moving like
like i don't know why it just it touches
me i think i think you would still like
the game yeah i really get it everyone's
saying this boss is in the game
anyway look we got volvo we've been home
i'm not against trump all right man i'll
catch y'all later bro
the legendary pg i'd love to pull it up
for our 10k salute bro no doubt so look
we got more ones we going on with this
way too long i thought we'd be done with
this topic
let's get the king
of smoke smoke for no reason let's get
this super chat that's how i come
through
mm-hmm
super chat
while you're doing that i'll take care
of some drip
shout out let's get um i believe hold on
total dope yeah total dope let me get
him right quick he got that uh classy
got the unity ilp joint congrats on the
10k
and then shout the flame he got the neck
gator he said i gotta stay hidden they
on to me
yeah everyone
if you watch his tick tock he got a
joint when he's in the snow when he got
on a net gator
i um i had to run to the bathroom last
night because this man almost made me
pee on myself he said for all your
people who wish for snow
yeah did they get out there
yo it was the most hilarious i think i
watched that thing 50 times last night
and i can only give you one like but
trust me i gave traction to that video
yeah it was uh
what's funny is is that got stolen that
[ __ ]
she sent a picture
of her with it and she's like is this
yours i'm like yeah i'd like your back
you're like no oh
oh she just jacked me that's something
that's different
we'll talk about that later what that
really is
she wants to wear the neck
okay
[Laughter]
no
we got uh abba cab 72 5 super chat
i'm surprised no one mentioned that kina
studios one of the first black studios
in the industry didn't even realize that
wow
so
shout out
ridiculous continue there we have
michael kulick 10 super chat you think
you think microsoft could be on boarding
crystal dynamics for a future
acquisition after this partnership could
lead to square selling the rest of their
western studios as well
since you're in that chat and i see you
as a member put a game you want the next
trivia to be in the comments section
uh that's what's up yeah i think king
has too much poet right now
yeah good time with the 10k celebration
i'm completely saucy yeah all right
[Laughter]
lord bronze
can't have sob being proud of me so
aren't we glad crystal dynamics can
finally work on a good game again
instead of avengers have a good show wow
that's terrible that's horrible
oh we got haruki cheney five dollar
super chat sadly and indie dev is being
asked to perform like a triple a dev
kina is fine yes it is this is an indie
dev
it is really good from the sides of the
team involved yes absolutely absolutely
you know we we have loads of i got to
plug the whole team lords of gaming.net
we'll be having our review we want we
got a little late you know i'm saying
but we did get a salute to emma lab and
we will give them the proper
feel with proper time as opposed to
rushing for an embargo so salute to them
though mm-hmm then we have michael
kulick again five dollars over chat hey
bg i know a pretty platformer you can
play psychonauts too with a nice wink uh
i think bg respectfully in the chat said
no thank you
he's not about that psychonauts like so
um and then we have one more we got
flame once again two thousand jack why
are you booing me i'm right
i guess somebody's booing him yeah i
guess
for a flav yeah we're good all right
we're good so attic i believe you're up
sir
this is
the heavyweight topic wait one more game
real good one more eyes all gamer you
know how he does two thousand chat attic
how long since you've had a booty call
mikey
[Music]
he's trying to act like he ain't
understanding
he's ridiculous
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
they say yo
yeah i missed the face said you missed
the super chat so if i'm assuming his
face he probably has some very
playstation pro playstation to say that
he didn't get off let me roll back
that's the holy face though he makes
sure that we get everything
the game that just came out acting like
i'm going to be able to have a question
about that
let's go
see if you guys could find it because
yeah do me a sec a face do me a favor
was it you yeah he said we missed his 20
super chat you got a 29 enjoy we messed
up all right sorry can you just put the
content of it no
real quick now we got to get faced we
got to get facebook i'll go get it i saw
i can get it i can get it get it right
now let's do it before we move on to the
next joint and then um
uh we have one one more element of you
uh five dollars for a chat i had to ask
is kina using that ssd for the fmv scene
wow
yeah so it doesn't it doesn't so
it doesn't do everything real quick
so we got our 20 hour super chat from
face kinder runs native 4k 30 or dynamic
4k 60 on a ps5 no checkerboarding and
ps5 kraken tech is doing wizardry latest
watchdogs legion patch is 3.2 gigs on
ps5 and 40. gigs on xbox series x can
this be a problem for the series
actually yeah yeah i'm i wanted you to i
want to address that um it could be a
problem that's probably why he's super
chatted yeah you know it could be a
problem going forward if i can get those
ssds to work
you know i mean honestly you're gonna
sit there and talk about kraken tech on
the old game
you'll finally compress the old game how
how big was it
compressed
out there look at the old game so let's
make it smaller microsoft was like we're
doing bigger things get out of here
we are not worrying about how small we
can make a game that came out alone
and
and i was good to go but you sit there
saying yo you know what we got 10 more
gigs it's rough over there if you're
worried about 10 gigabytes facing low
you know face rep blew hard man hey hey
hey me too i got blue right here just
for
y'all here with the old game
anyway moving on finally to the main
event attic you are up on yeah a lot
going on man you want me to set it up
for you are you good
because i set it up let me set it up
so
uh me and king or disagree on this
already no so
uh i actually it might be everyone on me
on this i don't know so
um as of a lot of you know on twitter
i'm sure a lot of you know we are
actually in the era where
uh someone a studio from square enix can
be helping the studio from microsoft and
no one bats and i so this is what
happened a couple days ago i think it
was on thursday or friday i can't
remember what day it was but
microsoft came out and formally
announced that it does look like the
initiative
is uh is going to be partnering with
crystal dynamics the people that made uh
tomb raider and i think they made that
last marvel avengers game uh and they're
going to be co-developing not assisting
co-developing
perfect dark so here's what i have to
ask the to ask the realm yes do you
think this is is signs of concern
and what do you think this is being done
because of if it's not a sign of concern
uh i i kind of want to start with uh
solving yeah because i haven't spoken to
him we haven't talked at all about this
well you said when it when the news came
out you saw that i put it in our chat
and our messenger chat cause i was just
like i don't know what to think of this
to be honest
it's sort of unprecedented to see
two aaa sort of studio sort of working
together
and and it being announced in this sort
of profound way um you know you have you
know you have support studios that work
on multiple games but to see it this way
and for perfect dog to be so early in
development
and and when you look at crystal
dynamics sort of expertise
it's third-person character action games
which they specifically said that
perfect dark wasn't going to be right it
was still going to be a first-person
shooter right so i i know in like the
press release they said something
specific about you know we're going to
be leaning on them for the expertise and
sort of developing
like bringing back old characters and
sort of bringing them
into the modern day and how to do that
properly right
so
for me it was just it was just weird to
see
for for a couple of reasons first
the fact like
when you delve deeper into it you see
the connections obviously the head of
initiative now use the head over the
calendar gallagher exactly so you have
those connections and they work together
on rise of the tomb raider obviously so
again that connection
um
it just
i think when i when they initially
talked about the initiative and what
type of studio that was they use all
these marketing terms you know quadruple
a this is supposed to be the best of the
best whatever and then when you really
dig down it into it like they don't i
don't think they even have 100 people at
the studio correct
so
then it makes you think okay what kind
of games are coming out of this are they
are they going to be super high quality
games that are 10 hours long
you know and don't take six years to
make
or are they just continuing to grow the
studio to make it into this this thing
that is comparable to like a naughty dog
or whatever you know an insomniac or
cdpr or whatever um
so i don't really know what this means
for the initiative as a studio like what
what are they trying to be really right
when they when so early on in
development they're partnering with this
other aaa sort of studio to sort of
the way they worded it felt like okay we
need to get we need to get
joanna dark right for 2021 and not mess
this up because then otherwise we're
killing the character again right um
so
it just to me
they're crystal dynamics is great
i think they're better storytellers out
there
if if that's what they're trying to do
and try to figure out that character i
love tomb raider i love the way they
brought tomb raider back right but it
wasn't perfect it fit for a fit for the
modern era but it wasn't necessarily
perfect but i mean
in defense of them i mean we we come
from old school
yes dynamic saturn when you know to
king's point you know it was more about
how good looking
and more about the puzzles than anything
than any story-wise whereas as opposed
to the reboot a lot of people who felt
laura was kind of fleshed out obviously
there's standards now that is right but
people felt like all right they kind of
gave her something yeah a little bit and
you look at you know you look at the
avengers game
by and large most people say the single
player stuff is the best stuff and the
characterization of kamala khan and and
um you know with this latest like black
panther thing people are saying like
that's great so in the storytelling part
i think
definitely they could be of help um
specifically how that applies to
anything else in the game again they're
making a first person game which i don't
think crystal d's ever done so it makes
me wonder kind of
where they're at with what they want
perfect dark to be
because of this partnership happening so
early on
and
obviously there's there's something
there because you know what was it 2019
we saw a video of phil spencer playing
the game right right right not we didn't
see the game but we saw video you know
phil spencer playing
so
i you know it just makes me question did
they have to go back to the drawing
board somewhere that they did they
develop a year in
you know right
on something and it'd be like no
this isn't working yeah that's really
the exact statement you know again
perfect update update we're partnering
with crystal dynamics the world-class
team behind character-driven games such
as tomb raider to bring this
first-person spy thriller to a new
generation and they follow tweet the
initiative says the teams couldn't pass
up a chance to work together we're still
early in development but incredibly
excited to see this unique opportunity
delivering on the vision of perfect art
so your thing solves your your concern
as far as
the stage of where it's at now the state
of perfect dark and what work needs to
be done
to bring joanna dark back remember
perfect dark is a is a
it's a what's up caller it's an n64
franchise there's a lot about that
franchise that needs to be updated and
brought up to modern standards for it to
resonate with a modern audience right um
so that's a lot of work that's a lot of
work so beyond wonder
i was going to say to be honest if you
saw
i felt like them taking that game in a
first person role was a mistake in
general but i felt like a third person
role would have been better i remember i
remember the speculation the beginning
what we wanted right we weren't getting
a splinter cell it was like well if you
bring back joanna dark
that could be splinter cell yeah you
turn her completely around and make it a
third person action game yeah but yeah
first person right yeah but see oh it's
first person the the thought about it
behind it is you know because of what
they did with god of war and they turned
it into a over-the-shoulder you know
sony holder yes you know
but can cut wouldn't you agree that that
worked out for them though no okay so
sometimes like people like for me
no it didn't and i'm i'm gonna keep on
staying on that drum you know
everybody's going to say but did you not
go to the last event just to see god of
war
huh
i knew you told me god of war was going
to win
i said i said i said god award save save
the for them because
but if it didn't work out for you why
did it save it for no okay okay so
let me explain about that game and what
how that game means right that game
means a lot to a lot of playstation 4
owners right so a lot of people jumped
into the playstation 4 ecosystem with
the god of war being at their first
entry point to the god of war series
right and it also started a new arc with
the god of war right and a lot of people
wanted to finish off more of that story
so when they told people that it was
coming out in 2021 the end of 2021 is
coming right now and they had multiple
shows where they didn't show this game
so that game had to be shown in some
form of capacity and i said this is the
proper time for that game to be shown so
if they don't show this game at the end
of the show or in this show it's going
to sink it for me right all that other
stuff i really didn't care about because
all i wanted to see was god of war now
people have problems with both
animations and all this other goofy
stuff
um all i cared about is that is an
extension of existing game and i didn't
expect different assets now
to sovereign's point on um them changing
and your point to them changing it from
a first person to a third person
no it's not the first person it's done
first person i mean
the desire for the desire
for people to
want that to happen
um
me know
like that's just like you know somebody
saying okay we're going to take halo
we're going to do that to halo i'm going
to do a little side project do odst
you know uh do uh halo wars
you know take a side project now you're
talking about this is the main title in
the series right and
um i believe crystal dynamics
their strong suit is their storytelling
right so maybe
me and [ __ ] talked about this on boone's
wonderful birthday on friday
right and
we explained that
when we're in the chances like you know
solve
if i'm going to go to war on something
i'm going to go someplace where we was
going to e3 or we going to packs and
we're going to go to these shows and
stuff like that
i i look for you there you understand i
look for the guy that i was in the
trenches with and the guy in the
relationship
and the dude that i know and the dude
that i can count on right so if i'm
heading a new studio and i have a bunch
of unknown variables at this time yeah i
can have confidence that they're going
to do a job but i can look at you and
know that you did the job right so i can
look at you with little visual cues and
you already got that you understand and
if i can get you a bag because this
industry is about a bag if i can get you
a bag i'm going to bring you in so i'm
pretty sure that um the head of um
initiative
formerly also the head of crystal
dynamics exactly
i'm i'm pretty sure that
he felt
that
in in early on in the conception this is
not no oh we're having a problem here
you know this is this is going to happen
i'm pretty sure he was the driving force
and bringing these dudes over to have
people in the trenches that he's worked
with and maybe he knows like okay y'all
really not working on nothing right now
we're working on this big project right
now this project has to hit
right this is not one of those projects
that we can play a game with or anything
like that they're putting a lot of this
just showing that they're playing a lot
of money and stuff involved
this this this must hit correct all
right so you don't call in uh barry
bonds to go hit doubles no you want to
hit this home run so you're calling the
people that can write and and maybe the
story was the weak point of where they
were at all right um because remember
this is the initiative's first game
right so we're looking at kinah at this
first studio this
indie studio uh putting out this
wonderful game and the background was in
this area right right they didn't have
the luxury to pull in a certain studio
that a triple a studio that they can say
yo fix this part right here help me get
past this part right here but these
dudes have the bucks and the money to do
so so if he feels that he's in the weeds
on certain things he's going to bring
these dudes over but i believe this was
done in the beginning i believe the
conception of the thought was it wasn't
no reactionary to where they were at i
believe this was a whole planned process
because they did say that they were
going to work with other studios and
doing different things going forward
with games so
um i think the only reason why it's such
a big thing is because it's crystal
dynamics because if they would have said
boo boo the full games he's gonna come
over here
but i also i think though let me give it
back to you sorry that we hijacked you
but
to king's point i hear what you're
saying about some people with
trepidation with certain things with
crystal dynamics i guess but you know do
you think cause one thing that i thought
was interesting is i've never seen
a tweet promotional
press release like like like almost as
if yo we proud to tell you
that we are partnering you know we got
logos on the side of a tweet like
normally historically
when you know obviously studios
outsource and stuff like that or or
whatever it is some type of code
development or whatever i mean shout out
to um
shout out some we have shout out to
splashdan we have the remember giuseppe
navario on ilp uh developer for gears
tactics remember that's coalition's game
but they brought in splash damage early
so i guess the question i think was but
that wasn't there was no tweet you know
what i'm saying yo
i can't right so i i guess my question
to all of y'all is that
you know is it because of the the way it
was done
that makes this seem weird that people
are like yo what is that about get at it
to me there's differences between
stuff like creative assembly making halo
wars 2
and um
splash damage making gears tactics
for the most part those games were there
from the beginning those developers are
there from the beginning like they
announced the initiative in 2018-17 i
can't remember which year um they they
they re-announced the game at the video
game awards where they actually formally
said this is what they're working on the
way that that was the first time we knew
what the game was
but to me
if this was
an all along thing that had been
announced there
this feels like it was one of the maybe
perfect dogs in the beginning right from
the no i'm talking about parker dynamics
partnership to me this is like a last
minute thing
to me this is like i personally this is
what i feel is happening i don't think
this is something to
like
you know fear i don't think this is
something to you know feel like the
initiatives incompetent or anything like
that i think this is simply
we have the leadership in place we have
the people in place but because of the
pandemic because how hard it is to move
people across the world across the
country okay to hire them to get us to
the work for our students we can't poach
people where we are very easily right
and we can't move people from across the
country where we are very easily so so
because the pandemics like it is so
let's talk to crystal dynamic let's
let's use our leadership and then
they're going to be the grunt work you
know
let me let me double down with you guys
off guys
see the grunt work thing is what gets me
because i you don't get a triple a
studio to do
qa for you you know what i mean
but that this isn't qa this is simply
them helping them with their but but i
mean 88 percent of the studios and all
studios
that's that's fine but you're talking
about a studio a that's already if
you're an avengers fan you're looking at
this like why aren't you focusing on
this i think i think oh yeah that's what
we're going to talk about i think it
simply is they do not have the lead they
do not have the
the force of the studio to to take on a
game like perfect art i think that uh
hiring people has been a huge issue for
for a while now because of the panda
like imagine you know hitting people up
like yo
we got you got to move though not in
this pandemic
development is different i mean it could
have again the dynamics could have
changed because of covert i i get it it
just feels weird to me that you would
drop the bag off for this type of studio
who's used to making their own triple a
games
we need you to you know clean up the
graphics
you know you're like
you know
the thing is i don't think there's much
of a game to even play
i i i think they might have some like
some uh what's that vertical slice thing
for phil to play to like figure out how
the game would play what kind of you
know concepts they wanted to put in the
game
there is a version of this that ends up
with as we said earlier now i don't
think this is possible i don't think
this is going to happen but it is
possible like square enix isn't in the
in in the what's worm look for the
mindset to lose money right so for all
we know
because of the whole marvel thing that
went on they're like yo you cost us a
lot of money that is that is
the fact that it's just like look like
instead of putting you on another
project don't be someone else's issue
and i'm not saying they're a bad studio
or anything like that but you know this
might be a way to low-key put score enix
on hold it's like we're not paying for
this right microsoft is sorry go help
them do that game yeah they they took
that back from microsoft solve before um
let me give it back to the king um what
about
you know some people say like hey you
know
like you said like you felt it was you
you still stand on your screen like it
feels weird right to you so it's weird
it's extremely so so my question is like
you know some people say you know why i
go you know get from the from the
microsoft standpoint like why not get
something else internally you know as
opposed to to crystal then what do you
say to that and and that's the weird
thing you have 23 internal studios that
have already talked about
you
helping each other and a lot of
cross-pollination each other with
concepts and helping each other build a
whole game two different concepts true
but they these are all studios that are
capable of building a whole game
but they're building their own
respectful game so let me give you this
scenario
how do we know that though we don't know
what crystal dynamics is doing anymore
so that means that they've abandoned
avengers and they did say there there is
a there's a job there's a job um listing
for the next tomb raider so the next
tomb raider is at the very least in the
conceptual stages so it's like you
you're going to tell me that crystal
dynamics has nothing to do
but
clearly if if square is
setting them over now to microsoft at
least this is just now now let's take
the argument from the square side right
that's what i want to go don't talk
about the square side still square let's
go um when it comes to squares
expectations for avengers let's talk
about it
yes they were astronomical yes
like comedically let's talk about that
western side of square that ain't moving
out here
they got all these astronomical
goals for what this thing let's be real
like
what's look at that
marvel avengers was low-key set up to be
kind of like a destiny killer even
though it has a single-player game they
thought it was going to be this
multi-player component live service
joint and that part didn't pop and let's
be real they spent a big bag to get that
license and all that stuff so we we do
have to look at the fact that
some of the western stuff from somewhere
a lot of the square western stuff square
has not reached their own expectation
can we at least say that
we can agree with that and the thing i
want to point out too
is like we don't know what's going on
behind closed doors we don't know for
all we know david uh daryl gallagher i i
i probably would do that
we're gonna get past this place you know
first off they just said partnership we
don't know if the entire crystal
dynamics is working on this uh i don't
they didn't really go into detail on
what type of work crystal dynamics was
doing for all we know score enix could
be considering letting crystal dynamics
go and it got back to daryl gallagher
and he hit up microsoft to drop the bag
off but they don't want to come out
formally announce that because they're
in the beginning processing i don't know
what's going on that's exactly right and
again that connection between the you
know daryl used to be there he's over at
microsoft now and microsoft having the
bag that they have right that is a very
real possibility right right um and the
fact that yes he
can square one
dissolve
their eastern stuff their western and
daryl
has been in three of those buildings
he's been right not only had the
christopher dynamics you know what i'm
saying he's also been associated linked
to square as well you know say he he has
ties there but to you i'm sorry here's
the question i have for you guys now i
don't think microsoft's about to buy
crystal dynamics i i don't think i think
mainly this is a relationship that daryl
was like yo uh you know some of you
helping but it's just weird that they
didn't reach out to your standard
studios that you would reach out to help
contractors they write you out that is
true published
that is unprecedented i've never seen
that correct now let's say that it does
go that way let's say within six months
two years microsoft analysis that they
bought crystal dynamics office square
enix
now now let's say that happens what do
you guys think would happen to the
studio do you think i personally feel
like there is no more crystal dynamics
they're merged with the initiative well
that's what i hit here's the thing again
i don't want to i want to go but i'll
kingdoms have not talked and i need king
to talk to get his muscles
i said enough when i jumped and hijacked
your um your point okay right and and me
falling back to the point is
uh there's much to do about nothing to
be honest with you i mean attic is
saying you know some valid points and
you guys are saying valid points and and
a ton of it is huge speculation you know
we go from
doom and gloom to oh it's not that bad
no no not from you
i do feel like
regardless who you are this kind of
scenario that so my knowledge has never
happened
this is a unique situation by a third
party publishers developer it is eyebrow
eyebrow i throw up a little bit one
thing one one thing to add
way right because of the name that is
involved but the name is important no
it's it's
so that's why the tweet is there
you know it's it's this is the tweet
don't go out if it's joe blow records it
just doesn't happen
it just doesn't happen
you know it's the fact that they've
given them their respect that you know
they're on here and yeah it's going to
raise a lot of eyebrows it's going to
scare the hell out of a lot of people
when they're saying well what what
what's going on with square enix and
xbox because we already know that square
enix said they're not up for sale
but you know a hostile takeover like i
always wish for like uh
is speculation from the king let's go
you know a hostile takeover
where where there's smoke there is fire
off all right so when you go to your
house and you see a size 13 at your bed
oh my god here we go
you've never heard of anything like this
before
we all talking
i don't i'm not going where he's going i
know we're here
but i will admit i will admit
that this is so unusual in the industry
that i've seen covering this industry
i don't see how that takes over it's
weird
but it is
it is weird that we know square don't
got nowhere to put them
like why how why are you if you're
square and you you
get wise
let's say that there is a world where
they're like
crystal dynamics sit down you're not
making any more games for a minute until
we figure out we're gonna let you go to
microsoft
no no let's say
let's say you know people are saying
they had nowhere to go with them you
needed to tell me no one else in there
like they have a bunch of pub games
don't be like thank you there's no other
projects
like i don't care what you say you're
walking and you're seeing the boots at
the bed so you looking like what the
hell is happening
whose boobs is is it is it is it they
coming for it they come with a square
they're gonna start slow with crystal
what are we doing listen i'm not gonna
cast aspersions on the situation but i'm
gonna tell you this where this smoke is
fire if you've never see if you've seen
something that's unprecedented happening
you're gonna sit there like wait a
second that's kind of strange crystal
like it was okay christian says send a
wife to somebody
yo all right let me tell you this let me
tell you that right
now so check it out someone touched on a
point in decent proposals
so you look my topic was playstation on
on phones so
yeah y'all love it continue let's
continue this right so studio and decent
proposal so all right so y'all looking
at the situation y'all like
square
they got stuff that they can work on
mm-hmm they were working on their
adventures what's what's spider-man
all right so check it out we know that
this spider-man content where's the
spider-man content but what we're going
to do is we're going to send you over to
this dude house come on
to work on the game that that's not
coming out anytime soon and that's my
biggest thing about this game
is like we're not talking about it would
be different if score enix let microsoft
because i'm sure they have like a
developer secretly that just helps the
other studios with games they took their
a team they said go help their agents go
and go help their agents
used to
is
[Music]
i know
you got to just let it happen you got to
let it happen because he been there
before
[Music]
it's like he knew the code
king's logic he knows the code to the
front door he brings the whole studio
down gallagher might be a swooner
like a lot of dudes is out there like
please no not square because if they
have a ninja square they're gonna have a
cornerstone on the market of rpgs
just let it happen
as he slips the knife
yo let me jump in he's the boss
he's a pretty premium content y'all this
is preview content listen oh man this is
funny oh all right first off
so i feel when you go with the
trepidation right i'll be initially
right when i first i'm like bro this is
weird like
where why are we making
press announcements
that you know you sending
you now yeah like
that point
has been blowing your mind for a minute
like y'all just don't understand how
he's been blowing your mind all right so
the wildest thing he blew your mind was
with zenimax right oh my god he's crazy
right and then and then he did he did
obsidian and all of those this man
he did the unthinkable look buddy
a triple a studio and put it on his quad
and the reason why he called it a
quadruple a studio because that triple a
slide up under there
[Laughter]
elizabeth here comes crystal dynamics to
work the buddy
watching you are sleeping
is weird it is very weird i've never
i'll be honest you know you know we owe
g's for most of us here and i've never
seen any axe never seen it so yeah you
know it went from first round this is
more than just the outsourcing right
this is like almost like a cold
development right yes we do have the
examples of industries with outsourcing
but never like this like this is you
know different instead of getting
now the thing is i gotta defend
microsoft on this part i know a lot of
people who thinks this is very well it's
like yo but they said quadruple a
actually they did it what it is is
that's the job posting like when you go
to linkedin if i apply for a job hr's
job is to make this thing sound like
it's degrading you're going to be flying
spaceships and doing this with our
studio of developers and like that's hr
speaker
if you actually listen to the galaxy you
actually listen to the initiative when
they did the video and they use terms
like we're trying to be small we're
trying to be agile right and they even
say in the video like we will be working
outsourcing stuff like that so they kind
of laid the groundwork already because
the fans
ran because remember that that job
listing got leaked like so the fans ran
over the four a's bro four a's bro
quadruple bro right yeah and we got
we're guilty of that part so i can't
give microsoft the smoke on that because
everybody i know this guy but i can't i
can't really give them i i see a lot of
people on twitter but like oh this game
ain't coming out anytime soon i didn't
expect this game out anytime soon
like 2024 at the earliest because like
they built a studio from the ground up
it's not like they bought a studio that
was already finished and established
right it takes a lot of time to build a
studio in the middle of a pandemic oh no
absolutely but here's the thing and i
think i wanna i wanna guess what makes
it more beautiful
here's the thing though but i think look
as gamers and i said this on boom show i
shout out to them you know breakfast
were born we me and king did that shout
out to the shop podcast i was on there
last night shout out to the sauce i was
on out making my rounds you know saying
but um you know the thing is
i think
as gamers you know what this remind me
remember when game pass first got
announced
it's like yo that's like i i've never
heard of that like huh how are you gonna
be able to do that you know what i'm
saying like it just was a concept that
was foreign to us in this space so to me
when i look at this
and
then then it became
oh
no not yet because
so it's like it's one of the things
where i'm like
like attic is making good points too
which like
we are so used to the traditional way of
game studio development and creation
right
and this
may be right because they did say small
agile in the outsource we're going to be
using other resource things like that
what if this is the new wave of game
development and let me give you some
bars
listen you said what if microsoft is out
here
let me go
let me get some bars though so could you
imagine you going home and you see the
side 13 next to you i'm done i'm done
so mr steal your chick is actually
microsoft
i don't know how they play with other
people's situations but
but they trace those but to steal your
girl that's
that's
all natural i got you but the thing is
like maybe
check them look at y'all like maybe it
was in our face the whole time but we
didn't realize it because you didn't
want to see it
the name
is the initiative
that's the studios there what if the
plan is we build the framework we design
the structure
and then we get
whoever the cloud is and execute
you're not making games that that you're
not making games on the level of alaska
or something like that with 60 with 60
people
but that would make sense that they if
they got someone right that i feel like
would make a perfect dart game right
like someone that that has a lot of
expertise in first person right
adventure games but like they got
they got the third person they got yeah
so that's where i'm a little like
disconnected i get you on that part the
only thing i will say is that it's again
even
that part
let's be real you said it yourself that
would be crazy though if they keep
partnering up with it like imagine if
they did something like that and every
game they parker off another with
another choice right they take it
they're gonna change the name of the
studio to the street song studios
if it's mr speaker
so here's
[Laughter]
the fear of god into all these dudes
that you don't know when the initiative
will slide up into your dna
what you're doing this weekend
this is the day means taking the the
this is okay we're gonna take the
initiative on this imagine let me try
this
yeah i was gonna say the whole thing is
to add it to your point right because
you're like yo but they don't make this
that in the third but you even said it
yourself in a pandemic hiring people
right hiring new people that's a
struggle to hire that amount of people
right
why not go and get the people that you
know that you work with you finish these
world-class games rise of the tomb
raider all this stuff is under your belt
and you know them you went like king
said you've been in the trenches with
them right it makes more sense to bring
in those people to work on something
different necessarily then they're
bringing somebody new that you got to
kind of see what's going on with the
report what's up i want to know if
people are going to have the same level
of vigor
when
something happens at
sony
and
the capcom head reaches over to the
capcom team
because remember
co-development
but i'm talking about when he reaches
over to capcom and pulls him over on a
project right let's say naughty dog is
doing or something like that but they
already doing it remember jason schreier
yeah
we found out that no we everybody was up
we're like yo why are we not getting a
days going to even me i was like damn
that's weird for sony and then jim ryan
it was like that direction is like no
you're gonna help cole develop this last
of us remake
don't remember it wasn't the code
development first
it was right you're making it you're
making naughty dog was like now we're
taking over yeah right the thing is
though it's a studio in their house yeah
see no no i get that bro i get that but
i'm talking about pulling over remember
the head of capcom
went over to sony yes yes yes all right
so i'm talking about him pulling over
capcom to work on a project that he's
working on in the studio that will be a
kid it is now if we see that happen then
maybe the initiative is on to something
right and sony recognized this and this
is the new way to work inside the how to
pandemic like i said the framework maybe
the initiative is putting up the
framework and this is how we want to
work
but then it goes right back to my point
there you go nobody's boo is safe nobody
will say but
here's the thing
and and i know everybody
there's some not everybody there is some
shot the pong and i see you brother
there's some people that's like doom and
gloom this is bad you know and i get it
all speculating here we all don't know
exactly we don't know what it is
a little bit worse though what the fact
that homeboy left six months to a year
ago right so yeah
yeah talk about the dude yeah that's
fine
but i'm saying this this is like
why ain't nobody talk about square
like to be square look is way
way worse they're like yo
yo you ain't working on marvel we don't
got nothing new nothing new for you hey
listen like i said we said it on boom
show i said it on on the shop with blam
and prong in them is that
at the end of it when you're in
corporate
the worst thing someone can tell you
when you've been brought in and hired
for a role
is we have nothing for you to work on
there's no
that is literally the next step start to
look like by the layoff yeah you know
what i'm saying because you your whole
thing in development or whatever it is
or like you have to be assigned to a
project these guys have road maps you
know what could have happened to crystal
dynamics we don't know
they might have got demoted to a uh a
studio that just helps people right and
here's and now they cause again we we do
again this is all speculation we don't
know but we do know
avengers ain't hit the way they thought
it was go ahead
and it cost them a lot of that cost them
a lot of brands you got to go hit the
streets right
so you got to go get my money right
exactly
how many of them solve how many is is
mad at them from that team right is it
what do you mean i mean as far as this
crystal dynamics as it's currently
constructed
i'm assuming yeah they didn't say they
ain't specified whatever the number is
you know what's funny good
they're they're out on probation and
they have to talk to microsoft how's
crystal dynamics doing
the fact that square made them available
for purchase square
square would rather take a bag
than to put them on a new project or
whatever is going on so to me it's like
you got
nothing for square to do
i do think there is a possibility
respect i do think there is a
possibility that they close down crystal
dynamics and we're just seeing the
beginning part of now we're doing
all those people right with the
initiative king
we know phil dominance has been known to
swoop in
captain saber when he hear things
i don't think that's it though
dynamics i think he wants the talent to
give him the initiative right and who
work at the initiative like to me daryl
gallagher's
i know how to get the best out of her
i like i i like i like the idea are you
are you implying that daryl misses his
wife wow
[Laughter]
award-winning things like so what okay
when i left y'all did this marvel stuff
facts when i left back
but when i was when i was there she was
at her best
it's like it's like mayweather miss
jackson i'm done what she would swing to
nelly she ain't look the same
but when she was with me
are you saying that we're about to get a
studio that has miles yo you know what
i'm going to tell you this right and
this is experience experience
experience i'm going to tell you i will
take crystal dynamics in the hot in the
hole
i'm making a lot of jokes and i'm being
real funny i'm being real cute it's
funny and let me tell you one thing
about crystal dynamics what they did
with lara cross that made me feel real
good about the scenario itself
when we first got lara croft laura croft
was eye candy right that had two guns
and it has puzzle elements
yeah facts the main aspect of it was the
eye candy you had the the the rear shot
you had the front shot and people were
going this way and that way with it
when they brought her back they
desexualized her and made her into a
heroine that we made her into a survivor
yeah yeah no they made her into somebody
that we can aspire to be yeah they
flushed her out the biggest thing i
didn't play a whole lot of those games i
did i don't really like those treasure
hunter kind type of games but what i
always respected about those games that
crystal dynamics made that i didn't
really like uncharted because they
didn't do it's like they made her human
yes
like when she killed someone you look
you saw the emotion in her eyes like
like at the end of the game you saw she
was beat up like let's see
to this point that's the point that i'm
talking about joanna dark needs that
remate because yeah she's really kind of
a character that's not flash like she
was [ __ ] then there's a 90s character
like right so now that you have this
company this studio and you can say what
you want marvel avengers story is fire
if you play
i just want to get this bar off that one
bad mother said because he think we
wanted something too he said i wouldn't
be shocked if microsoft tries to take
squares western division neither crystal
dynamics nor idols make money and that's
what i'm trying to tell you that western
division over there they put a lot of
money
for this vicious
gay type micro transaction games and
service type stuff and it wasn't moving
over yo yo i'm sorry i gotta go
let's go this tail derek i went to score
enoch's office and started smashing
watermelons until they offered up
christmas
unbelievable
let's see
how
guardians of the galaxy hits yeah and
then and we could talk more about this
dlc there no guardians of the yeah
let me okay so listen this is my thought
that's a dlc for one game
oh my god
let me tell you something i thought
garland is a galaxy it's probably dlc
for
um avengers and they said yo we got to
disassociate this game with that game
because this game is throwing stuff down
because i hear everybody talk about
black panther uh uh dlc and everybody
keeps telling me yo it's lit yo king you
gotta go oh that's fine bro
let me ask you a question what's up had
they just released that game and they
had a little bit more to it and it was
just a separate black panther game oh
this would be fire you understood so
that's what i'm should be fighting if
this was a set if these are single
players separate games they would be
getting lauded because it is very
difficult to do good narrative good
voice it is really well done i i can't
and let me say this last ball too i know
we went along with this
i'm gonna be i'm people gonna say okay i
don't care
that if y'all play that joint bro like
have you played it recently
from uh
which has a while
but from a graphical fidelity standpoint
that game in my opinion is one of the
best and it's a cross gen game that is
one of the best looking games right now
on next gen hallway in my opinion it is
that beautiful do these still shots do
your photo i'm telling you that game
look for now as far as talented
developers as far as story
as far as graphical fidelity i cannot
take that away from crystal dynamics i
can't you could say hey you didn't like
avengers and you didn't like what the
direction of the game was and maybe
that's the square it's not i don't know
but i can't take away from the talent
cannot you know you know the biggest
thing that crystal dynamic has that i've
always given respect for
they got trees blowing in the water
shout out to them
[Music]
chat the initiative needed a ride and
phil rented them an escalade studio
he didn't cop them four or five hundreds
got a studio on wheels boots in the room
whose 13's is though
who taught you how to do that
continue
there we go element appeal five dollar
super chat crystal d has that triple h
we're not
[Music]
doubt and we have phase all assigned
five dollars to the chat
do you think the initiative will focus
on bringing up the quality across the
first party games to be more polished as
opposed to just another xbox studio
jesus christ
we'll see
[Laughter]
[Music]
smart pawns continue
then we got black rolling with the
twenty dollar chat
you know they put no type of dna
then we got cd is being brought in to
help with grunt work the initiative is
doing the main creative portion such as
story setting character design and
pushing that to cd for deeper coding
naughty dog did the same thing with the
last of us too you know the more that we
talk about it it may yeah it kind of
makes sense i guess if if this is what
they are and they're not growing past 60
something developers
then yeah maybe they just they do that
portion and and pass it along this could
be the way they handle second-party
development from now on so who knows
and we got mr irish five-pound super
chat this partnership clearly means
microsoft is taking playstations
final fantasy sugar daddy off the board
mark my words that's that's the easter
diminisher they're making money
they're making money over there yeah i
don't know about that i don't know about
that
the next question for the the for the
free code is what is the final fantasy
game where the main character is the
dark knight
okay okay um okay
then we have um
chaney five dollar super chat just to
point out sony had 14 studios work on
the last of us too most of them not
owned by sony xbox can get a cd so they
got cd
then we start we got dono taco 20 super
chat the initiative is said they're
staying small and agile i think they're
they're there to build the world
shout out to ireland
i think they're there to build the world
and vision of the game and then they
move on to a new project and leave a big
third party to finish off the last one
while overseeing you know what the more
we talk about it kind of makes sense who
knows
the new face of second party development
then we especially for game pass um tony
bryant five dollars for chat y'all why
by the way we need an all-natty shirt
make it happen we on it we gonna get the
emojis we got a shirt yeah we do it all
right everything that y'all see when
y'all see the little man you see all
natty yeah beta boys all that stuff
t-shirts yo they tweeting me on twitter
yeah i'm loving the crystals
indiana jones and the crystal d yeah
we got king one supreme five dollar
super chat phil disonly first i'm taking
your wife mlb now i'm taking this side
piece square
then we gotta and i said this is my don
king boys splendiferous two dollars
square enix sit on uncle phil's couch
and get comfy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we asked xbox to be competitive cd
initiative is microsoft money at work
hashtag book of acts yes phil dominance
is dominant
then you've got the wise old gamer five
dollars if we chat microsoft to sony's
slash square
your girl cd
she belongs to the street
[Laughter]
[Music]
happy 10k lords no concerns with this
gen's xbox and their decisions whatever
they do and whoever they get to help
will be dope trust mm-hmm
i hope so
then we got a picture for g two dollar
super chat square put cd in the corner
now a lot of mercy
then we got uh easy shot two dollar
super chat gallagher was lead for there
was x uh human revolution first and
third person yeah so we we haven't
spoken to the fact that it could there
be could be moments where she jumps out
of here but it could be we don't know
what's going on and because with all the
gadget stuff
if i recall it did happen in perfect
dark zero yeah
yeah so it could happen um brett bingham
ten dollar super chat
didn't sony also have another publishers
games as exclusives who was that again
oh right it was bethesda
for all sony's third-party exclusive
publishers and more
i don't know let me see who else we got
my god i see jw it's a shell there yeah
it was j.w okay i got you said that was
uh brett bringing was your last one yeah
and more j.w i got it you got it oh now
you get it you get it jw is a shield
five dollar super chat yo i thought
getting crystal d was the thing that so
many guys like wow what are we doing
here
yeah this is good
shout out to homie ray g full time phil
drinking all the red kool-aid at chris
all right man last time crazy that's
kind of crazy oh my god split difference
2000. sony needs to replace the logo
with 343 craig and i guess he got a
dancing emoji i don't know that's jim
ryan
yeah he must be yeah
okay he got the absolute salute to you
[Laughter]
anyway oh yeah last time this be
nintendo direct nintendo had a director
i don't know who got a chance to catch
it i watched it i had to meet you dude
shout out to y'all dudes tearing up
every surprise for me sorry you're
kidding you see i crazy yeah i'm like
thank you i really appreciate you but
these two dudes over here these two
dudes i just after that crazy thing i
was like bye like
you know i sat there me and you sat
there at e3 and watched a treehouse
joint that was terrible yeah it was
absolutely terrible i watch all of these
joints because i really like how they do
this stuff but i'll be honest with you
y'all kind of messed up a lot of things
for me like
i was like man how are they gonna do
that like that was the biggest reveal
for me like that crazy thing but then i
was i was kind of pissed off well one i
was happy that they dropped it that day
yes two i was kind of pissed off game
passes dropping a whole bunch of games
so i'm like that's gonna have to wait
for a minute i know my uh nintendo ain't
gonna go down in the price anyway so it
don't matter like i could get a cheaper
price and it was all digital so
i know what they're doing i know the
angles that they're doing and stuff but
y'all kind of messed it up for me though
i'm not gonna lie i couldn't wait for
this topic to tell y'all what y'all did
we did this so look for those that did
not you know spoil too much for uh for
king let's start what you saw like what
do you think man what was your thoughts
on the direct
gotcha i honestly made it feel like kind
of like a banger like especially for
stuff that mattered to me like
like king said yo uh act razor for me is
it's one of those things it's a game
that i came to
by mistake because i was like i i don't
the side scrolling looks cool let me try
it out and then
the god mode stuff is what really drew
me in in a way that i never expected
back in the day i played that game front
to back i loved that game and just it
was such a random announcement and to
see how beautiful that game is yeah it's
launch title it is and then this this
here to bring that back we always ask
for this game yeah yo so the one thing
i've played it for about an hour or so
the one thing is i wish they would have
made the side scrolling like the combat
maybe a little bit more robust because
they updated it
it's pretty it's pretty but it's still
simple
yeah so but other than that like the god
mode stuff it looks beautiful yo they do
the they do the mode seventh thing when
you drop down from the heavens like you
know
did you have an act raiser too yes and
they took out all the god mode stuff
yeah they took out the stuff that made
it yeah that made it unique exactly and
they made it just a run-of-the-mill side
scroller that was not great that looked
like it was going up against golden axe
exactly
so that was that wasn't the move so
obviously that the castle i mean
legendary actually sorry that's a golden
number oh yeah
then the castlevania advance collection
was huge for me like again
uh symphony of that is one of my top
five of all time and these games are
exactly emulating that and because it
was on you know game boy advance i
played a little bit that was more
kaibatsu's thing i was playing you know
i wasn't about
you know the portable stuff so much at
that point plus like the the back no
back light and it was just i started
them i was like nah i'm not doing this
so to be able to have them on this oh i
got them on the switch because i have
too many big games to play on my big
consoles to get it on those so i just
got on the switch and it's it's
beautiful
obviously
listen i am not a fan of nintendo
continue trying to extract money from
people feel like the hustle
with the online stuff and the and the
n60 you get your genesis control
i'm good i got a video baby i'm good
you're not getting that 64 controller
you're not feeling grandpa trying to
monetize
your emotions yo they they are so good
at that it's so funny how people just
looking at that hating and and but ready
to click quickly
so so that to me finally
get it though
they get the fact that see what i like
about nintendo and they always made
noticeably lost like 50 viewers when
this
is
it's cool um for those people that did
stick around yes
it's gonna be dropped in the chat so
yeah
don't do that thank you um
but
they get control
yeah
has always been about control they
always revolutionize how controllers oh
for sure you know going forward so like
when they showed the n64 controller and
you can play these games in its original
form i was like wow that's that's dope
and then you know for the for the sega
genesis and they had the genesis
controller and they're like yo it's
wireless too like so we're brought it up
to the ages of now
and but you can still use the same
unique control so you don't have to feel
this place because how many times we
play emulated games
a new controller on a 360 controller
right right right
they respected that art form like you
could do it this way you can play it
this way with the switch stuff yeah but
you could do it this way i thought that
was cool i thought that was nice i mean
they're very good at sort of picking at
your nostalgia that's for sure and they
and monetizing it they're very good at
that so but again i don't know addict
was like oh my god i'll buy this so i
get it
um
so bayonetta finally being shown
bayonetta 2 is one of like it's a that's
an amazing action game bayonetta too and
they finally
if you saw bayonetta i don't like
nintendo having a property
[Music]
she had a tremendous amount of clothing
on
no no no no no
this is nintendo's brand yes right so if
you look at the first bayonetta yeah
you know where she was fighting and her
hair would cause our skin her suit is
her hair right so when she fights and
she makes these constructs she's
basically being naked and they were
doing little art form things to cover it
right so you can never really truly see
anything
but i think nintendo saw it and if you
look at the first bayonetta and
bayonetta and all the way to now this
one literally
is is a wealth of clothes not saying
there's anything wrong with it
yeah the history of the character
doesn't lend itself to that they're
still trying to have her in this sexy
type of lingerie because that's what she
was fighting and yeah lingerie and now
she has a tutu dress that's really puffy
and poofy here around the top and i was
looking at it saying that
i think that distracts away from the
originality of the character from the
beginning even though that's just
something i've said even the gore has
been told oh yeah they toned that down
that's nintendo yeah
that's definitely then um and then the
last thing for me surprisingly
is that kirby game
yes that was the best thing for me
kirby
first of all was funny because the first
thing when i saw that i was like last of
us
it was an abandoned mall and i was like
what what kind of post-apocalyptic thing
is that you see kirby face down in like
the mud or whatever
um but again kirby has traditionally
been a kind of a more child-centric
side-scrolling thing and it's never been
like the deepest platformers where
they've been pretty like you know uh
what the hell was that the
kirby's epic yarn and stuff like that um
but it just been very child-centric and
this although still you know touching
upon that it's the first time you see
kirby in true 3d yeah
um
nintendo's top characters you would
expect them to be placed in real life
robust games and kirby's the one that's
never really gotten that treatment until
now
kirby has a lot of moves if you play
smash curry
he's a very powerful character
to see that to see that realize in a 3d
world i'm super interested to see
because this might elevate kirby a
little bit you know what i mean like
and make him so more appealing to the
masses as opposed to just being this
kitty thing
depending on how they do it so that was
interesting to me very excited um
again i was not expecting to be this
excited over stuff but again when you
two things that i love drop on the same
day yeah yeah you're good
let's get attic man where you at with
this direct
i liked it i thought it was a solid uh
direct i didn't think like there wasn't
a lot in there that like appealed to me
but
you know
when it comes to nintendo i don't really
i never expect to like everything to
appeal to me because they don't they
they've never claimed that they try to
be diverse they're like look you don't
get what what we
were giving you
or you could go somewhere else like
we're not gonna we're not gonna chase
the bag you chasing us not the other way
around
so uh yeah i thought it was cool
bayonetta three surprised me because i
thought that game was cancelled i ain't
gonna lie to you right uh so it's nice
that that's happening and you know i
know that to a lot of nintendo fans
getting that bayonetta reveal was
everything to them so i'm glad they got
that uh i personally want to play mario
party when it comes out because it's got
an online infrastructure so
you know we might we might have to play
a community night with that man
who's
[Laughter]
we will have the iron bank five four
coffees calm down
i finally got to see my uh the
game that's like a kind of a spiritual
successor final fantasy tactics yes so
that looks really good so i was looking
forward to playing that
yeah shout out to the name just being
triangle strategy yeah yeah triangle
triangle crazy yeah how's it kick what
are your thoughts
i like the whole show i like i like um
everything from beginning and even the
games that i'm not truly interested in i
think nintendo's knows their niche and
they know how to play do they crowd very
well
um i think they get it when they you
know bring out little things to make you
catch fomo that you have to have these
things that you
don't really need but you really want
and you know how to pull at that um pack
razor was a huge surprise for me because
i thought they would never automatically
right so um i thought that was a big
thing
the sega
catalog thing
let's talk about let's talk about
nintendo and they online
um
direct smack a spit in the face of game
pass
it was like yeah um we're gonna have a
thing too
and you can play these games
with the plus structure
uh our online nintendo plus we'll talk
about the price later yeah they're
always about that you know nintendo can
always get away with telling you about
something and they're not telling you
the price and like we'll discuss it
later
thing about it is like what do you think
that price is going to be because it's a
higher tier right it's a higher tier
right five to ten dollars more oh
how much is that i do want it now it's
20. i i do want to say something real
quick
i handled all the people that won the uh
trivias we're not going to play no more
trivia i gave like four or five codes
away so i'm going to probably drop about
15 codes in the chat between now and the
end of the podcast nice that's what's up
ready y'all about ready get lit about to
get blessed all right you call your
friends in here um
it's just
they do they do their thing right you
know nintendo knows this space they know
the i love the metroid um my standout
was the kirby and the metroid i've been
waiting for this metroid for a long time
and have different powers and do
different things i'm so super intrigued
with how they're going to tell a story
and what's going on and they're making
sure that we know the same as is
a super bounty hunter the best bounty
hunter in the galaxy
um and and they're leaning heavily into
that and i and i love what they're doing
there and kirby they finally recognize
kirby as the action star hero that he is
um he's eating little dogs they try to
avoid that
in in a couple of instances he saw the
dogs attack you but he wouldn't you know
i was like are they enemies are they
friends like and then i watched a little
bit more of it and then he ate one and i
was like oh yeah
so
you know it it it was nice it was nice
to see
and
um do i ever oh
um
dying light too yes let's talk about it
grandpa it has been he got his club
yes seven
yeah it wasn't even seven it was control
it was resident seven and it was
something else i think yeah and
they they've shown with that um nvidia
um tegra card
uh and an infrastructure they're able to
stream that card is built around that
whole aspect of it
and it's showing that they don't really
have to go
up to to get um some form of fidelity in
their graphics and they're streaming the
tech off of or whatever um hardware that
they're streaming it from but it looked
pretty decent to me yes i mean if if you
don't have and they still showing you
that they can get these uh aaa titles
that are launching on next-gen consoles
on current gen hardware
um they're doing a good job yeah that's
i mean four four if if you're into the
uh the ecosystem they're they're going
above and beyond for you because i
noticed nintendo would have never done
this in the past and i see nintendo
breaking away
trying to compete and they're doing it
in a unique way that fits only how
nintendo would that's yes no i agree i
agree i mean it was definitely it was
weird because i can't even like addict
like you do i watch these shows i'm like
ain't gonna really have enough for me
and i'm gonna be real like lately no no
this one yeah but i said lately i've
been really cool on what has hurt my
switch game love is
in a pandemic world
like that's you guys play different
y'all switching from me you guys play
your switches mostly in the house right
now i mean i mean
yeah you're a king an attic king is play
day switches in the house me and solve
play our switches on the go like that's
us right so with the pandemic and stuff
and and just things are different i
don't really take my switch out thus i'm
in the house and i'm not playing switch
over playstation series like that's not
happening you know when i got the better
version so
i'm like and then when the stream the
steam deck got announced i'm like
oh man this is looking it's looking
spooky i don't know if it's gonna be
coming out hot anymore
i don't know if it's gonna be covered in
that so that so me coming in this was
like i don't even know what's going to
keep me over here for a long like you
know when the janitor's getting they're
getting longer to finish in so i watched
it i'm like i ain't gonna fight grandpa
had some joy for me i was like hi
he's like look we got that act razor
joint okay cool let me end up getting
all right cool
metroid dread looked absolutely amazing
to me mm-hmm
absolutely amazing for a person who was
like all right they need to go to the 3d
and that's you know i still want the
prime stuff but i was like yo that that
looks bad fun the boss fights i said
that pneumatics like kid was saying the
bounty hunter drink looked fire you know
they came for me with my sega love you
know what i'm saying all right we got it
for you if you interested you know even
though we charging when we shouldn't and
we understand i'll tell you this though
they got that 64. i know this is never
probably going to happen but i'm going
to tell you right now the king i because
officially will bend it
if they say
they got the no mercy choice
or that they're just
online bro they get in the bag from me i
will take any slander i have said
against them if they got them
www nwo joints or the no mercy in that
64 packages
virtual
console it's surrounded by planes that i
mean they have plans
virtual console wasn't in it bro dumb
wrestling games
it is on i don't care how much they
charge it they got me better than me
because they would have to they would
have to go back and really like you have
to go one by one all those different
character licenses
right but
it's so worth it but here's the thing
like let me ask y'all cause y'all we you
guys like when they had the virtual
console did they ever bring stuff like
that nah they didn't bring those that's
what i'm saying i'm just talking about
it
i didn't do too much virtual console
stuff okay anybody okay you did virtual
console stuff at it
no yeah you made it knew mike and he
made it
my bad no to be honest with you i didn't
really mess a whole lot with the um
like the emulation or anything like that
so you know okay uh
and but you know i i played a lot of
that that was wrestling games back in
the day on the n64 but like
i didn't really care about the to the
extent you guys did if that makes sense
like it is my world if they came back
they came back like i'm more upset with
the fact that they can give us a price i
feel like that's really spooky
as much as i love
those games
to me
i would have like instead of playing i
don't want to play the 30 frames
offering the time for the n60 oh yeah
yeah you would want the remaster you
want the remaster so look yeah i'll
finish up um last thing i said metro
jack kotor
[Music]
oh
[Music]
look also low key i thought disco
elysium was a huge get yes that game is
critically acclaimed playstation has it
currently
and uh that's what i thought i'm like yo
by now i thought when nintendo showed it
on this i was always going to be
multiple and i'm like and i see people
hitting the discord legion so where's
the xbox version like what's going on so
oh they got hades first they got they
gonna hide in six months
[Music]
had the exclusivity which is fine right
and then now this baby up with this
deluxe version and i see it on switch
i'm like okay so that means xbox is
going coming yeah where's that so that
was it last point i'll say the next move
yeah hopefully last point i'll say is um
or maybe game pass that would be lit um
that'll be i'll be super fine please
throw that on gameplay
all i gotta say is what i gotta say is
there's been all this speculation about
microsoft buying uh sega yeah you heard
it here first nintendo's buying sega
thank you oh
well i will say it was quite interesting
to see
those controllers in there but whatever
anyway long story short the controller
was interesting that was very
interesting you're promoting another
console with their artwork they've had
sega on their virtual console before yes
many times
put in the boot on the neck yeah that
has to be fun
yeah that's been a while disrespectful
anyway yeah and b83 was a nice to close
the show but look that's all i got we
got to get up out of here we went long
long and gone um new ilp poll with the
recent announcement of the initiative
partnering with crystal dynamics on
perfect dark how confident you on the
development of this game moving forward
the choices are a
not confident it's a red flag if a
microsoft quadruple a studio has to
enlist help from a triple-a early in
development for their first
game choice b
very confident initiative studio head
already has previous relations
with
crystal dynamics to make great games
feels like home studios outsource every
day be
[Laughter]
see i don't care why is it square
getting any smoke for pimping out day
studios like that yes
shout out to everybody in the chat shout
out to king felix that pulled up shout
out to everybody in the realm 10
000 subscribers
listen i'll say real quick we did this
our way i'm very proud of what we're
doing
um you know obviously for the most part
we are just a podcast you know which so
to me is a little extra special we
really don't do daily videos we don't do
these other things that you know other
content creators do it the fact that you
know 10 000 people choose to take time
out their day to come here even when
they disagree with us you know what i'm
saying even the troll or whatever like
it means a lot and yeah your boy before
he got emotional you know hit hit hit
the homies up and i'm proud i'm proud
you know i didn't see this kind of thing
for us and see how it's brought us
together in the community behind us i'm
very very humbled by that salute to
everybody who who's helped us
along the way who's either guested or
you know just always show support and
love it really it really means a lot and
i really want to thank y'all the realm
is super dope we're very fortunate i've
never seen a community like this that
supports us in the way they do the super
chats the tweets that when they throw
the crest up the merch like it's
different it's different you know and
i'm not trying to talk down on anybody
i'm just very humbled every time we come
in here and people
show the love to us so that's what i
want to say i want to shout that out
before we move on but uh attic you got
anything to say to the people and 10k
subs and king phoenix
a lot
it's really hard to grow on
youtube and if you don't make daily
content or you know short-term videos
because obviously
when it comes to podcasting
it's it's for a demographic you know
it's not for everyone no one's gonna sit
here for
damn day or sometimes four hours and
sometimes even farther than that yeah so
it's it's hard to really appeal to that
kind of audience because they're not
wanting to watch that type of thing
but because you guys coming here in such
drones every week
you get us into the algorithm you know
we might not punch it too much but you
know we get a little bit a little
identical
and you know throughout the the the king
of statute the combat talk the attic
show well attic shows kind of a podcast
so that'll really count but you know
other things that we do uh the r rs you
know those are our way of giving to you
guys a different perspective of us and
also you know growing the channel for
more than just gaming which has
unordinary leaked to us too you know
also cognito going defining duke i see a
bunch of you guys always in the comment
section saying that you came from there
uh you know there's been so many
variables that has led to this 10k
moment
and you know it's like i was talking to
them earlier we was at like 4 800 at the
beginning of this year yes
uh you know i got acg
um
colin moriarty you know there there's
been so many people jeff grubb we've had
a lot of people
willing to come on our show because you
what you got to realize going on people
you don't know show is there unless you
go and watch everything they've ever
done facts you have to blind jump into
podcasts and i want to shout king out
too because even though he was having
fun with king phoenix it's like one
thing that we know we're on to something
on some level is that you know sometimes
secretly we won't put them out there
some guests will tell us hey we got a
hard stop after 30 minutes or an hour
and we respect it right
and then the to me one of the biggest
indictment in a positive way that that
you know what we're doing is is
something good is that with people like
yo
i'm good i'm staying for the you know
what i'm saying like i got tired you
know what i'm saying i'll extend let me
see a little bit low i thought that's
dope look at the attic
and yeah i just i want to point out like
you know we wouldn't be anywhere without
you guys the people that watch
uh the camera i'm on this mic you know i
got the mic that cognito has now i can't
really move it too much damn immediately
oh you know i got a green screen i got
this light so you could see all my
glosses beard
you know shout out all that came from
you guys you guys coming here you
support every week uh we appreciate it
we like we don't joke no one gets
anything from what was put in the
podcast what we what is put where that
money goes is what you're seeing now the
cameras the the
the codes i mean i've been giving away a
bunch of codes in the chat uh so you
know we do all of this we always try to
contribute back we always look for ways
to improve the quality of the podcast
and all that's because of you guys oh
yeah for sure for sure
lord soft
what can i say man like i said i i thank
you guys for for asking me to be on this
sort of journey with y'all because you
guys are out there every day hustling
you guys are personalities out there i i
come on and do the podcast
and maybe every now and again i could
make an appearance someplace else
i'll listen to the whole thing exactly
shout
do this send this tweet out i am not
link my
my twitter is not linked to my
all right tag me and then i see it
shout out to song capri yeah sean
caprese is an excellent person just to
talk to it's a homie um
but
it's the thing about a podcast is like
what addict alluded to this is a live
thing like a lot of people do content
and it's you know it's a video you put
up and that's how you get engagement
walk away from him and you walk away
from it with the podcast it's all about
the live engagement that you have
with with your fans and for us
to see that growth
over the course of what is it now what
four years
when you have you can't even get your
parents into the chat you know at first
and now we have anywhere from like 500
to 1000 people i've seen in this chat
that's
good i do want to point out that code
that i just put in the chat that is for
uh game pass ultimate shout out to
look man your name is complicated
i definitely appreciate the uh shout out
to him for donating the code
that's all i just thank you so much
so it's it's a special thing it really
is to have you guys
rep and follow us and be here week in
and week out
um listening to our banter and listening
to our foolishness and the thing is the
foolishness is who we are man
uh i alluded to it on the the
conversation i had with sean capri it's
just like man
these these are relationships that were
kind of in hibernation for a long time
you know what i mean until we until we
got this dynamic back and
it was literally in the matter of a
couple of weeks when we
found our footing and the dynamic was
just right back to what it was and
and i think
the people that listen to us see that
and it's just about hearing that it's
about the banter back and forth it's the
fact that there's there's there's a real
connection here and
um i would have never on my own
decided to come and do something like
this so i i thank cog all the time to be
like addict pushing me into this
you know be it to it i'll just like dude
i'll grab y'all
because it's like you know you don't
realize what you're capable of sometimes
until you sort of they you're throwing
off the ledge and uh
this is this has been fun and i i can't
wait to see what happens you know i i
can't wait to see where we are in the in
the next you know 10 000 subs no doubt
words from the king
man there was a very historic day um
from having uh king phoenix on
um
y'all guys don't really know how big
that moment is
because maybe sometimes you know you
guys
poo poo moments i'm i'm a big
visualization dude and i'm a big
alignment guy yeah you know you know it
aligned up perfectly yeah you know
so um
the the symmetry the
it it fits
to get to
10k it means a ton because you know
these guys are telling you that we don't
do daily content we're not streamers
um you know we're not putting videos
together
and trying to hit an algorithm and doing
something like this we come to you guys
honestly raw
uh who we are yeah and you like our
personalities and you tune in
like they said
you can't even get your parents to watch
um
but i can have somebody in germany
buy a t-shirt
sometimes because
a lot of people watching everywhere like
that's crazy he's saying to me like it's
really insane to me
um so that's why i tell you guys like
i'm on xbox i i see a lot of guys oh you
know if you're part of the patreon you
can talk to me and my in my xbox
or my playstation you could join my chat
and they made a lot of dudes chats
there's a lot
my chat is open if i don't like what
you're saying yeah
there's so many
like it's gotten so ridiculous sometimes
with king like keeping his shadow but so
much i'll be popping in there be like oh
18 people in there i think i'm good on
that
you like bye but i'm in there listen
i'm not gonna change i'm gonna be me i'm
gonna say jokes a lot of times you guys
don't understand
this is jokes for me yeah you have fun i
don't really care about none of that
twitter wall i don't care about it
yo you know why they could they could be
as mad as they want to be with me nobody
was sleeping out on the sidewalk waiting
for a playstation 2.
so don't sit there and tell me oh how
lit you are and
and and how how much you rep sony yo how
blue your blood is you didn't go out and
buy a sony xena sony zh1
uh hd1 remember that uh sovereign that
television costs me three grand so i can
have a 1080p television
don't you tell just to go with my
playstation 2. so don't you tell me who
you are and what you rep when you don't
even buy a pro don't you tell me who you
are what you rep and you ain't even got
a playstation 5 but i had i stood out
overnight and got it i'm supposed to be
the xbox dude i rep video games no doubt
i get everything i have everything and i
rep everything just because i talk xbox
stuff as i know it bothers you
keep in mind you know there's uh things
uh
that's all the codes i'm giving out i
literally gave out like i think like
almost 15 codes
i appreciate everyone coming through and
now look
i i'm i'm not calling you out man i'm
not calling you out because it's not
your fault all right it's not but
pycon vision i'm gonna have to find a
better way i'm gonna start doing the
question mark because i'd be seeing you
say thank you for that code too much
i think i'm going to start aiming for
really popular indies because i want to
give a lot to those indies too
so i'm going to start aiming for english
and you know yeah it's like you know but
see the thing is place it's harder to go
to the playstation like chris wright
chris hart that's in the in the chat you
say it's only xbox codes dude go talk to
playstation we can't yeah yeah it's like
tough getting i'm gonna tell you right
now getting playstation anytime we had
giveaways and somebody and somebody
asked for place like i can give you we
can give you ps plus like money right
but when it comes to specifically a code
for a game
that is very hard to come by um that's
that's a playstation we're going to work
on because eventually we'll work on
doing it i'm going to do the question
mark thing i'm going to do the question
mark oh we're talking about that i just
tell you guys thank you yeah for sure
but people tell you i i really
appreciate you and i really appreciate
how
how good y'all are in the chat yeah like
i i i go to other people's uh channels
and i see how nasty they are in the chat
and you guys really treat each other
with such respect i mean y'all go at
each other here and there but it's
really respectful
you know i really do yeah i think i
think what it is two kings after just a
certain amount of time
people know because we've been around
because we've been doing this since for
like three years like three or four
years
people know by now it's like look this
is how messy i could be this is how
messy i can't be if i'm too much people
will tell me out and we we're pretty
linger when people do too messy yeah but
like we reel you back and we say don't
do it again we like pop you on the nose
yeah exactly
we let you guys you guys police
yourselves pretty well yeah that was
good y'all was cool with that crystal d
yeah okay
i'm done
anyway look we got to get invited here
that's all i got attic um anything else
you got as far as giveaways so
we
no more don't expect to give away for a
minute i'd literally just i i shot all
my my logo
here in the next two to three weeks i
gotta talk to saul because he's the one
that's his schedules all over the world
we're going to be doing that um
chivalry live stream
uh so uh be on a lookout for that i'ma
try something new
but i have to talk to them before i'm
willing to announce anything in terms of
that uh keep in mind uh this tuesday 5
p.m the attic show come through there
watch it be in hustle talking about uh
the past president and future gaming
last last week it was me incognito and
also it's a nice little show i
appreciate everyone coming up
you know like i said man
we got a great chat we got a great
community and you know if there's
anything that could ever happen
we built this community because you guys
like the content
and we like each other enough to keep
doing it exactly factual
okay let me go hold on a second let me
roll back a little bit no i could not
finish the bottle
please though
i quit halfway through
i got we got tonight
we got stitched two dollars of a chat we
need a crystal d emoji
we'll be right back
uh then we gotta get to the point
already though
five dollar super chat but get to the
point already xbox knows that alphabet a
for arcane studios b for bethesda c for
coalition d is for diamond d
target
lock and loaded time
ridiculous there we have alex escort
five dollar super chat shout out to you
guys influencing me to try buying a
comic and i tried something new dark
ages and i'm hooked already that's
what's up nice no doubt
then we got donald taco member for four
months thank you sir for everyone who's
asking for bayonetta to go back
multiplat blame yourselves so not buying
the first one on 360 and ps3 yes that is
that is kind of the only reason that is
kind of the only reason that nintendo
was able to get that and no i don't
agree with that because at the end of
the day i think games could sell well
but if that bag is right they're not
going to care because they're going to
get that money because of that bag so
why would they care about where it goes
yeah i don't care
but i don't know how much
the thing is
would you i get that but why would you
want
what if money would you have right now
money yeah
remember for six months no doubt then we
got don otaku ten dollars with a chat
2022 is looking too good xbox with
starfield red fall stalker two day one
game pass nintendo breath of the wild
two maybe bayonetta three mario ravaged
two 3d kirby ps5 horizon 2 god of war
ragnarok for spoken word 2023
yeah probably that's another one
then we got relish gt five dollar super
chat first time captain y'all alive
nothing will kill destiny until they run
out of story congratulations on the 10k
warlock
there we go stew jersey ten dollars good
chat thank you my brother please say
something no doubt drinking after stew
jersey hold on a second then we got lord
metroid
lord metroid five dollars super chat
konami finally stopped drinking sake and
playing them pachinko machines because
the castlevania advance collection is
great yes uh i've what i played of it so
far is fantastic
apart from the fact that they give you
the the whack uh super nintendo of rondo
black
no don't play that one don't play that
shout out to donovan's he bought that
stainless tumbler he got that tumbler
with the iop logo getting the cold
beverages on you know what i'm saying
warm on hot you know yeah the logo keep
in mind that's four minutes that's since
we have ten thousand dollars okay for
the chat i was gonna say now since we
have 10 000 subs we can actually put our
merchandise in the in the description
below yeah that's coming that's coming i
was i was very too thirsty youtube said
you got to chill you just got to take
care relax
relax you got to get out you got one
more super chat from the liz 22 member
for eight months had to drop off to
watch my patriots stink up the joy
that's the second half of the show on
podcast just want to say congrats on 10k
on to a million
millionaires
roughing you up
shout out to the liz man
that's the clan what's up
oh nothing uh
nothing all right you good everybody
good luck man thank y'all 10k
onward and upward we are going to do
more things looking forward to it catch
us next week same bat time batch a.m
eastern two kings and alexis smee
we will catch y'all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
[Music]
you